Two one and we're live. Hello
Gabby. Hello. How are you doing?
Good, thanks for being here. I
appreciate it. Thank you for having me.
You're looking well, thank
you. You are as well. I uh,
I really enjoy following you on Instagram.
You have a very positive Instagram page.
It's full of information.
It's beneficial.
It's great stuff.
Thanks. I, uh, you know, I'm, I feel
like I'm trying to figure that out.
Like for a younger person it's like,
oh yeah, well this is how you do it.
And for me I'm like, well what do you
really want to say? And I don't know.
I think sometimes I,
I would like to take more chances,
but I do play it probably
safe. How so? Like in what way?
I try to be pretty honest,
but sometimes you're always very aware
that you'd just amount interested in
getting roasted or spending a
lot of time and energy in a,
a hassle with somebody. So I think when
I'm doing it, I'm as honest as I can be,
but it's also, I'm aware of
that. What do you hold back on?
Like what kind of stuff?
I think for me it would just,
maybe you'd just be more even maybe
more direct, but you're, you know,
I think when you're trying,
when you sort of say, okay,
I'm going to occupy this space
professionally, that feels good to me.
And like I want it to be
overall pretty positive.
You know?
Like if you're selling something,
like maybe I'd like to try
to sell something positive,
but hopefully towards
the honest a little bit.
And sometimes when you're doing that,
you're also aware that like you're not
as harsh as sometimes your inner voices.
And so you go,
well,
am I not being completely honest and
transparent because I don't really want to
deal with it and I, so I'm just saying,
you don't want to deal with feedback.
Comments. Yeah. And it's, and it's also
just people who are frustrated or, or,
or also they're not getting maybe the
nuance or the subtlety of what I'm trying
to say. Let's just say that
social media is not the place for
subtlety. No, not in the comments
for sure. Right, right. So I just,
I want to do stuff that seems like that
seems authentic. You know, pretty real,
but hopefully skewed towards like
either fun or something positive.
Mm. One of things that I've recognized
from doing a podcast is the, uh,
some of the frustration when
people do lash out and you're like,
this is like out of proportion.
Some of it is due to the fact that it's
very frustrating to just not be a part
of the conversation if you disagree with,
when you're listening to
just the fundamental, the,
there's the act of listening to someone
have a conversation and something comes
up and you're like, but what about
that? That's a great point. Say that.
And it's like this, you get
stuck. Yeah. It's get angry.
So then we leave it a shitty comment.
I'm like, oh, that guy's a dick.
But it's point, his frustration
of not being able to communicate,
interject. It's like your kid
who'd be like, hey, hey, hey.
And they never get to in.
Yeah.
That's a great point.
I think you've probably been tempered by
doing this and have probably looked at
it from a lot of different points of view
because you have to, yeah. You have to.
I've tried. No, it's,
it's been interesting to like
watch you over the years.
I think what's interesting is watching
you have an interesting place where you
keep your own,
you sort of keep a level of neutrality
even though you have an opinion.
So you let other people
express themselves,
whether it's about a religion
or a vaccination or whatever.
I think that that I,
it's been interesting to see like
you develop that skill even more.
Well, it's hard for people to
express themselves as it is.
Like live on a podcast is difficult.
It's harder still if you don't
allow them to. If you interject,
and you know as well as we
all know that when someone,
when you have something you're trying
to say and someone talks over you,
it's fucking frustrating.
And when you trying to formulate these
words than someone butts in and then you
lose it,
it's hard.
So that's one of the key
skills of learning how to
communicate with people that
we think a lot of people lose is
the ability to listen. You know?
And also you have to have a good enough
memory so you can hold on what you were
going to say and then allow this person
to elaborate on their thoughts and then
when you give them the respect and allow
them to elaborate on your thoughts,
hopefully they'll return that favor and
they'll allow you to elaborate on your
thoughts and then you'd get a
much more balanced conversation.
But there's so many people talking where
they're just talking over each other
and shutting each other down or taking
the conversation into a weird place.
It's just I'm the only way to find out
how someone feels about something is to
let them express themselves and if
people get mad that I don't push back,
that's not always the best way
to find out how a person feels.
You got to let them let them talk.
I want to know,
I want to know the whole thing.
I want to know as far into this as
you can tell me why you think this.
Like instead of me just saying,
no, you're wrong. I want to,
I want you to explain it to me.
I want to know whether or
not I trust your process.
Do you bring that scale home with you?
I mean, you're surrounded by women.
It's trough. It's tough, bro. I,
I, I'm serious. Like sometimes I,
cause I even see it with my own husband.
We have three daughters,
but I mean, especially, you know,
when you have a pretty masculine male,
I'm always fascinated to
watch them navigate their
home when they're surrounded
by women.
I just give up. Most of the
time I lose every argument. Um,
I think, um, you know, I tried to,
we communicate a lot, lot of talking,
a lot of get upset with girls.
It's always there always things they're
crying about and you're like, okay, okay,
okay, we're going to be fine. And you
know, I don't want them to be like me.
I want them to be themselves
and I want them to be girls.
I want them to be able to be themselves.
I don't want them to mirror my resilience,
you know,
I want them to be vulnerable if they
want to be vulnerable. But it's a,
in terms of like how I decorate the
house or any, I don't have no say, oh no.
That's why you have, you know, I have this
place. I was going to say, you have your,
your cave here at Laird has a
barn. Perfect. And He, you know,
when he meets young guys getting married,
he goes, here, I'm going to teach you.
Okay. You're right honey.
I'm sorry. And Oh yes.
Whatever color you choose,
you know, always work. Some
people it's never enough,
but if all that is the
right relationships,
sometimes it'll work that way because
I don't give a fuck what my house looks
like. I really don't know. I have a
good view. Where's the coffee? Yeah,
real work. How's the bed? That's a good
bed. Do we have a TV? Where's the TV?
Is it a good one? Lots of good TV.
All right, we're good. We're good.
I have a laptop. Okay. We're good. Yeah.
Yeah. I don't need that much. You know,
so like when my wife's like, I want to put
this here, I'm like, okay, put it there.
Fantastic. I want to get that painting.
Okay. Get the painting. I don't know.
I don't know where you want to put it.
Put it where it feels right.
I don't give a fuck. I
think it's smart. I mean,
you know like sometimes if I am fringe on,
if it's functional then layered steps
in like you know that's not really
functional,
but otherwise he's like,
I'm tearing some stuff out of my house
right now and he just gives me a look and
I'm like,
I'm this age if I want to do this,
support me. And he just laughs and walks
out. He just probably doesn't care.
It's in the way. Whatever it is,
whatever, have fun with it. Yeah.
What Time's dinner? You know,
and love to decorate things.
I get nervous if a guy's really into
it. Well yeah, it's a nesting track.
Guys are like really into like
the design in their own house.
Like really,
really into it.
Like constantly obsessing about where
things are and where I supposed to call
those homosexuals. Yeah. I can't
plow. Yeah. What do you mean?
Is that a stereotypical thing? That
is outrageous. What? He's not racist.
That might be,
he might have showed you white supremacy.
Yeah. It's a funny thing. Right. But,
uh, if I didn't have this place though,
I don't know if I,
like traditionally men had pool halls
they could hang out at or gyms that they
would hang out in and they would
get their dose of toxic masculinity.
Her basement basement.
Yeah.
You kind of take you to a place where
nobody's touching your stuff. Yeah.
Well if you live in a house, like
I do with all girls too. It's,
it's just everything's girly. I just,
whatever. I'm fine. [inaudible] said he,
he's like,
I need it to be more specific.
I said I want it to be
surrounded by women.
I didn't mean to be
related to all of them.
That's hilarious. It's, I think it's
a nature, God's way of balancing off.
They say if guys have elevated
body temperature, so athletes,
people train a lot that
they're statistically have
a greater chance of having
daughters because I think they hot,
we call it hot balls basically,
if he kills off the male
sperm. That's hilarious.
And if you look around, I think so
they did a thing on a bunch of guys,
either in the NFL or whatever.
And statistically they just
have a lot more daughters.
And I think it's like
nature's way of going, oh,
you're going to be all like moving
and active and raw and all this stuff.
Guess what?
They're just going to put a bunch
of girls around you for you.
Because my daughters say things to my
husband. I could never say as a wife,
you know, it's like I see
it and I just go, oh yeah,
well they know that for sure. He loves
them. So they carried away with it.
They're in, they can't get fired.
No, I always say that to them.
My youngest daughter, when she was really
little, like five or six, she'd say, okay,
so I'm not really clear with
this. Um, when I have alone time,
I'm by myself. And when you and dad
need alone time, like you're together.
And I tried to like,
well you know,
it's important for moms and dads cause
you know, we have to work at it. I go,
you know, you're, you're always going
to be dad's daughter. I, you know, I'm,
we're working at being a husband and
wife and a then she'd keep going with it.
And um, I finally, it
would just say like, Hey,
do you want to have
Christmas in separate houses?
And I'd see her thing for a second, like,
well, maybe, you know, and I'm like,
we need a long time. I get to
present. That's what I mean,
she's processing that. She's like,
I miss you, but I dunno. You know,
so it's all that dance, you
know, cause daughters, man,
they don't miss a trick and they're
on you and they're on their dad like
nobody's business. While my friends
would have sons, the way they say it is,
it's like you take one of two things.
Either you have this wild animal that's
tearing things apart or you have someone
who's screaming and crying about
something you don't understand. Yeah.
Take your pick. You want until judo
mental destroyer or a physical destroyer.
Yeah. Walls with holes and broken,
broken bones. Boys and girls.
It's like I have learned so much
being a mother, two daughters,
and I've been around women my whole life.
You figure playing volleyball
and being around tons of women,
it's very different as a parent.
I mean I've learned the most,
especially teenagers.
They're watching them grow so strange.
It's such a strange experience watching
a person figure out the world from,
from jump, you know, like out
the womb, figuring out the world.
It's so educational.
I feel.
I don't think everyone
should have children.
I'm not one of those zealots
that tells everybody, Hey,
you're not alive until you have a kid.
No,
I think it's unfair to say that to people.
That's unfair.
I think it's first of all,
a lot of people can't write and maybe
they have a just a different path.
Like I always tell my girlfriends too,
like it's unfair also to romanticize
like to your friends who either opted not
to have children or whatever, met a
partner too late or didn't or whatever.
Because I think it is a really rich,
I mean there's nothing like it.
I mean, I love my children,
but if I have one friend,
she was like got married later and she's
like, you know, we're going to adopt.
And um, she was also doing a new business
and I was like, listen, I need to come,
I want to talk to you. And she also liked
to consider taking naps occasionally.
I was like,
if you think you're going to adopt and
like you're going to have a 12 year old
that's like a, hey, I really appreciate
you guys. Thank you so much. I go,
that's not what you know, like if
you think you're going to have a kid
and it's gonna make you happier,
that's not what having a kid is.
I think it makes you,
it makes you know yourself better in a
different way and you can adapt and do
something different. But I think when
people sort of sell that bill of goods,
like, oh, you got to have kids. It's like,
well, do you want to have kids? You know,
I think it's like you said, not for
everyone. You definitely shouldn't adopt.
You think it's going to be easy.
That's what I mean.
It's like she had this romantic idea
of like, and I go, you know, you don't,
first of all, you don't know what the,
what's where the kid is coming from.
And then also you have a romance.
I think every parent going into
it has a romantic idea. I did.
And I'm a pretty realistic person of like,
I'm going to do all these things right
and it, we're going to be, you know,
running in sunflower fields together
and my kids are never going to think my
music sucks or I can drive. And then
you realize, I had a friend tell me,
everyone gets their turn in the
barrel no matter what you do. Uh,
you got, you have to navigate
stuff you're going to,
to deal with stuff for sure.
And on the other hand,
it's awesome when someone does adopt
people, if they're really into it,
if they know what they're getting into
and those martyrs out there and those
people that are just super kind and
generous and love to adopt children of God
bless them. So glad
they're there. It's just,
I agree with you that there are some
people that have a romanticized idea of
what it's like to raise
a child and it's unfair
to to sell it. Like, I
loved the mom check what?
So when are you going to have number two
or whatever to somebody it's like, oh,
you know that they're behind
closed doors doing, you know,
like they just want everyone to be
in the psychotic ness with them.
I have three kids. You should
have three kids. You know,
there are people like
that, right? They did this.
People that have a kid then immediately
take this moral high ground.
Like so like they're doing something,
they're an adult and you're,
you're just a fool. You're
layer. I wonder who is the fool?
I ask myself that sometimes.
Well,
don't you think you're a better
person for raising kids? Do you,
does it make you feel like you're more
in tune and nicer and just more aware of
what it is,
what it means to be a human?
Yeah. I not only that I, I feel like,
I feel like it's,
it's a forced exploration.
If you're trying to participate, like if
you just lay down the law and go, hey,
in this house, this is how we do
it, then you're not doing anything.
But I think if you,
you learn to adapt and also go,
wow,
I was doing that wrong for like 10
years. Amazing. You know, like I've,
one of my daughters,
I had 12 or 13 sort of revealed some
stuff about what she was unhappy about,
about my parenting, and I was like, God,
I've been doing that for a long time.
Uh, so I think it's cool that she
had the confidence to do that though.
Yeah. It's so cool. I wanted to hear that.
Like when she was 30 at the Thanksgiving
table, she moved out. I was like,
what? You're supposed to reveal all that
like after you move out and then I go,
oh, what did I do that? Sorry. It
turned out great. It's amazing.
What time's your flight? Uh,
no, I think, no, listen, it's a,
it's a surrender. I think for me
it's been a real surrender because I,
I just think I, you think you're in
control of stuff and you think, oh,
I've got some discipline and work ethic.
I just work my way through it
or power my way through it.
And then you realize like, no,
you have to surrender. And,
and also it's not just about
solving it quickly and, um,
yeah, it is. I'm, I know
myself certainly better,
but also it forces you if you're
willing to, to really expand and it's,
it is uncomfortable.
Well,
I've been really fascinated by the
life that you guys live in Hawaii
because I've always had this
like idealized, like one day,
like moved to the big island,
just chat on the side of a mountain,
stop fucking out,
fly out to do gigs,
but live out there where
everything's just more relaxed. Yeah.
Know is it okay?
You know,
there's a lot going on and like the Big
island is obviously big city. Yeah, no,
it's been a while. It has, it's
sort of like la on the beach,
but you know,
there's a couple things I think because
it is a primal environment like we live
on quite, which is pretty
heavy duty as far as, um,
it's quiet.
There's not a lot of distraction.
There's a really heavy duty nature.
And um,
and so I, and I grew up in, in
St Thomas on the Virgin Islands,
so I was used to kind of being
on an island. But it, you're,
you're with yourself a lot,
so if you have things to do that are,
you know, productive,
then it's perfect. Um,
but what you have to always
calibrate is like, um,
the downtime or it like,
it's been raining off and on for like
over a year on Hawaii. Whoa. Yeah.
So after a while it'd be like
Seattle in that way where people,
it starts getting heavy, but
it's sunny too, right? It can be,
and it's the weirdest thing
about the islands. Yeah.
There's different climates on this island.
The Big island has desert.
Yes,
it has tropical rain forest is a volcano.
There's all this shit in a snack.
Every, I think it has
every, uh, weather climate,
except Arctic,
I believe at least Maui and the big
island have sort of every type of climate.
It's crazy that just a little bit
further down. It'll be different.
It'd be raining constantly. Yeah, exactly.
Or You just go the other
side and it's completely dry.
Or they have dwarf trees because they
never see the sun, but then they're,
you know, 200 feet in the
places that it's sunny. It's,
it's pretty trippy.
And you could drive around the whole
thing and like how many hours does it take
you to drive on the Big Island?
The Big Island? I don't know,
like four hours or something like that?
I think so. Maybe a little more. Yeah.
You like the big island. Love it.
Interesting. I like Maui. You do?
That's my favorite. Every
island different. They're all,
their personalities are
different, but I like it. I mean,
we've been doing this for over 23 years.
When I met Laird,
he was big waves sort of come in winter.
So when low pressures brings snow,
like to the rest of the mainland,
that low pressure can also bring big
waves. And then my season was summer,
so we sort of went back and forth.
And that's a really good blend because
then you can come to California and be
like, oh, it's a busy world. I can see
a lot of people. I can learn stuff,
I can do stuff.
Um,
and then I also makes you appreciate
when you go back to Hawaii,
you're like clean air,
really clean water,
very beautiful place.
Um, some of the ways,
the ideas about the way they live
there, it's, it's simple in a good way.
I don't mean that in any
way, like a derogatory, it's
like they're not trying to,
they're not angling and
trying to get somewhere. It's
like, no, we're living right.
Um, but it can be also a very, a
really hard place. Really hard place.
Well, I think, you know, and you're also
talking about a warrior culture, right?
Polynesians.
So you have like this,
this very intense love. And, uh, you know,
when they talk about the Aloha
spirit generosity, they ha like this.
And then they're very
powerful people as well.
And sometimes if they're living,
not living as they're in their most
natural way that they were supposed to,
and then you couple it with, um, you know,
there's not a ton of opportunities there.
It's hard to live there. It's far away.
It's expensive. Um, and,
and sometimes, uh, you know,
it sounds Cliche,
but it's like we really do as human
organisms either need to be busy,
so like, okay, working from
sunup to sundown for our food,
which is how it used to be,
and then you're just so tired,
you just go to bed and it's pretty
simple and let's just survive it.
Or in the world that we live in now,
it's like,
how do we get people doing things that are
kind of productive? And, um, you think,
oh, I just would sit on the beach and
look at the mountain. And it's like, yeah.
And after a while you get bored.
And if you're a warrior,
you're either gonna go, you
know, do something with that.
That is good for you or
you might not. So, um,
I think there's, there's a
lot, a lot of that there,
I've learned a lot from that
culture. Um, but I mean,
they're pretty powerful.
They're powerful group and, uh,
you know, it can go the other way
pretty quick where it's, you know,
if there's drugs and alcohol are
beefing and like it's all that.
So it's,
that was really disturbing.
I found out how much drug abuse there
is on some of the islands. Yeah.
Crystal Mathis especially
sad. Well it's, it's, again,
it goes back to the board and like
thinking about when your kids have to stay
home for one day. Yeah. You know,
it's just, and now we have all these,
the internet and all this stuff,
so now you, you sort of think, oh,
the rest of the world has a perfect,
they're all busy and doing fabulous,
perfect things. And um, and it's hard.
Like you got to find people
that you're like, let's do
something. Let's go. I mean,
can you train alone every single time now?
So you'd have to have a tribe
of people that are like,
let's go do this activity. And sometimes
they don't. It's not that easy. Well,
so there's, there's just
say there's 70,000 people on
the island on [inaudible].
He's probably the least, uh,
inhabited, it's the oldest island,
so it has the most erosion,
largest beaches. Um,
and that's where Larry grew
up. And it's a, it's a,
it's a really denies the loose inhabitant
of the islands, isn't it? Well, yeah.
I mean I don't, it's not that
I don't count it. Yeah. I
mean, of the bigger islands.
Yeah. Molokai, man, you wouldn't, you
don't, you don't mess with Malkai. No, no.
That's like,
that's like you,
but you got to ask permission to go
hang out over there. I'll Kinda, yeah,
it's cool though, cause it's like, if, you
know, if they'd be like, no, you gotta,
you can't, you're out. You got to
go. Really. Totally. So it was great.
Is it's just the people that live there,
you can't like move to Mollica. Yeah.
I mean like, you know, I had, Eddie
Vedder has a place on Molokai. Yep.
And has had for many,
many years,
but I think he probably asked if that
was going to be cool. Oh Wow. Yeah.
Interesting. Yeah, it's,
and it's beautiful.
Do you have some friends that
just went hunting there? Yeah.
Beautiful access to here. Yeah. Yeah.
It's a beautiful place and the people are
amazing, but you, you, it's not like, oh,
I'm just going to buy a house there or
build a house. There's no way. No Way.
No Way. Wow, that's interesting to do.
All these different islands have
their own rules. Well, Niki out is a,
you can't even, you can't go there. No,
I didn't even know that was a, an island.
Yeah, it's off of cooperating
Nikki. I'll give her that.
Jamie's big fan of,
he looks like he's mentally,
he has none of that. It's all
like, they probably have the,
uh, the, you know, the largest
percentage of pure of Hawaiians there.
So it's cool. I mean, pretty
good. It's got to be a great view.
I've found that like, there's a
big difference between the, the,
the culture of say Maui
versus the culture of Lanai.
Lanai is more island d to me,
whereas Maui seems like little
bit gentrified. We'll also,
the wind cause it Maui,
so windy,
it brought all the Europeans
in the 80s to wind surf.
So you're also have not only mainland
us and then Japanese culture,
you know, eighties now you're talking
about Europeans for wind and wind surfing.
So it has a lot going on.
I think Maui,
it was almost like a surprise how quick
it developed and they never had a chance
to get on top of it, if that makes
sense. That does make sense. Yeah.
It's so populated and
it's also like, so, um,
it's so la Beverly Hills, I lived
there for 13 years with layered. Yeah.
There was a wave there that Laird was
having a love with for many years.
So we lived there, uh, with, you know,
so he could be close to his
girlfriend for sure. It was strange.
It didn't know every boy needs is their
girlfriend. Every boy needs a wave.
They do. Well girl, you
know, just something,
that's what I always think is kind of
natural is at least for my experience is
like,
I don't know if he ever go through this.
When you go home I'll Laerdal
go out and surf for many hours,
like kicking off for five hours at a
time and if their surf and he comes home
and I see how happy he is, like to see us,
like he loves us. He's like, oh my girls,
you know. And then about, I dunno,
seven and a half, eight minutes in,
he starts to get this look
on his face like, oh yeah,
I'm in the house with the family.
You know,
I want it to do a book years ago called
death by domestication because it's like
how does, how does, how does he manage
both of those sides? Like, I need to go,
I need to be free, I need to, you know,
chase things and like scare myself
and do all this stuff and then,
you know, comes home and he's like, you
know, on the floor laying, you know,
with one of my daughters and,
and being attentive and a great
husband and all these things.
But I always get amused
a little bit by the,
yeah, well especially I think
with the big wave surfer mindset,
like a type of person,
those are like some of the freest,
wild as humans on the planet.
It's a very unusual group of people that
rides giant waves of water on the top
of the ocean.
I mean that's a,
that's a crazy thing to delta here
time to really stop and think about it.
I try not to think too much about
it cause I did marry him, but I,
there's some stuff, I mean
and, and weirdly, you know,
he's been doing this so
long that you realize hit,
he's actually even more different than
some of the other guys because if you
think about it, he sustained doing
this for right now, 40 years.
So he's a guy who
he has both.
So what he wants to do is write a huge
wave during the day and then be with his
family at night. And sometimes, you know,
it would take going halfway
around the globe or whatever.
And so I think the pursuit
and they have to wait a lot.
That's the other thing. These things don't
come around that often. Right? Um, it's,
it's very interesting to
live with because, um,
there's a,
there's a little bit of suffering that
goes on and sometimes layer it will say
to me, cause he's aware of
time going by, he'll be like,
you don't have a lot more waves. I
need to ride. And I'm like, I know,
like it's a pretty deep,
uh, calling. And now that,
I mean he's been foiling for 25 years,
but now that they are getting
that equipment better,
it's sort of like now we can ride
places that we couldn't ride,
that we're not really attractive for
riding on top of the surface of the water,
even if you towed it. So now it's
opened up a whole other pursuit for him.
Um, yeah, it's very, I know
why you would go towards that.
Like Laird has put me on a ski in front
of a way that's like 60 feet. Right?
And like being on the back
of a ski with him driving,
there's a moment where
you go, okay, I actually,
and I'm sure you've experienced this
with other friends that take you maybe on
up flying or something. He is, this
is what he does, right? So I'm like,
okay, I trust him more than
I'm afraid. That's fine.
I can do that and I'm
going to surrender to that.
I'm not going to torture myself the
whole time. I'm just going to trust him.
And you turn and there's a six
story building behind you moving
and you just think, who would,
who like, well how has that fun,
you know,
like how is hang like I'm
going to actively ride that.
But now what the foils,
because they're actually catching the
energy below the surface of the water.
So foils, I'm not familiar. They have
these things called the hydrofoils.
So originally there was a guy named Mike
Murphy who created something called the
air chair. And they were, they'd been
putting foils on skis, water skis,
and different funky ways.
Like even in the 50s so layeredness
friends got an air chair,
cut the chair off and put
us snowboard boots bindings,
quick release. So you'd stand on
it. You're booted in and below.
Is this basically a mini airplane
with a Strut? So for example,
yeah, there's a shot of one and
this is a smaller one. Jamie,
do you have any ones of the
big with the boots? Yeah,
Larry. This is what people are
using the old time memories.
Do you know what about this? I seen
him. Wow. He knows about everything.
What are you talking about? He's
plugged in, plugged in, look at them.
Do you have a girlfriend? Well, what
happened to this dude's head? Oh yeah.
So there's layered on the left obviously.
So you see how he there
in the boots and also he,
the reason it looks so puffy as he
has flotation underneath his wet suit.
So if you hit your head or what have you,
but it's basically a miniature
airplane underneath the surface.
And if he gets into trouble, if they
wiped out, um, they have a quick release,
but now they've gotten this
developed so that he can do it, uh,
without the boots because that adds
an element of danger that cause you're
strapped in, you're strapped
in and your strut is, you know,
four feet long. Uh, you know,
that's so strange looking.
Yeah. But it's what's going on below the
surface. So there's a miniature airplane.
Do you have, Jamie, do you have
any pictures of it flipped up?
I'm sure if you look on Laird stuff,
you can see the bottom,
it's like a miniature airplane
because water is denser than air.
So it's sort of like a miniature plane.
And it is like the oracle guys that do
those boats do have made foils for Laird.
Um, it's, so that's what
it looks like. Yeah.
So those are kind of more
a low performance ones.
When you see the high performance,
they, I mean, you know,
it's aerodynamics.
It's all of that.
So now what you're doing is because w
there's energy below the surface moving.
So we think of a wave like pushing and
dropping. But there's actually the energy,
circular energy below. So now you've
got the foil that can ride that and,
but you're not, you don't have
drag. So like they can go,
there's a wave on [inaudible] where
they're going over, you know, 50,
they go about 50,
they can go get up to 52 miles an hour.
So imagine if you did something, we'll,
you've dedicated yourself to martial arts.
It's like,
but then there's like a new way to do it.
And so he's been doing the
big stuff for 25 years,
but now they're using the equipment right.
That he can ride ways that
actually wouldn't be that great.
But now they're super fun.
Oh Wow. So he gets it,
makes them excited and he still
pursues it. And, uh, that's,
that's on why right there and see how
it's not even breaking where he rides it
so it can correct.
And it's,
it's actually riding the energy
below the surface, which,
you know, for him, he's just interested
in what's the most efficient way. I mean,
look at that. You'd never
enter in, um, regular surfing.
Be able to ride that.
So it enables them so much fun.
You're flying, that's what they say.
That's the difference. Right? So
they're flying. So that's, I think,
keep kept him interested.
But you know, his,
his pursuit of this is,
it's pretty,
it's pretty, it's a pretty
interesting relationship to watch.
I think it's important. I
mean, as a female for me,
I think playing volleyball
helped me understand like
having a pursuit, you know,
like something like I got to go do that.
And I think it's something about living
with a person who has a pursuit other
than, um, like I need a
bigger war chest or whatever.
That's can be really cool is when,
when you're riding that thing and there's
the little airplane under the water,
is there any risk of something
thinking that airplane is a fish? Um,
no. Animals are pretty smart.
Yeah. I don't, I think, I mean,
I know sharks don't have great vision
and I think Laird is, uh, you know,
hit a home, a turtle, you know,
not done eating by like
grazed did or something.
But those animals are pretty smart.
Well, but I was thinking the sharks now.
That's what I mean. I go maybe a
Marlin who thinks it's fish? Yeah,
I don't think, I don't think they want
to have anything to do with that thing.
Just the speed and the shape.
And also a lot of those animals
don't want to get in that turbulent.
It's still near a wave.
But you know what maybe you never know.
And if I hear of a story I
will definitely call you.
Tell him cause I'll be like a Marlin
came out. But those guys are smart.
All those animals, you
know, lens or smart.
Well I mean they not usually,
I know sharks again don't have great site,
but they're not like,
Huh.
I think they understand
what's most times what's food.
Obviously shiny things
and things like that. But,
but there are instances of people
getting hit by sharks, right.
In Hawaii is a big one,
isn't it?
Thing you're swim worse as far as like
more and South Africa is really a lot of
sharks. No, Hawaii has
their fair share, but
nothing crazy.
I,
there's a story that happened like three
weeks ago on quiet and Hanalei Bay,
the sky great surfer finishes his ride,
jumps off his board and jumped
onto a shark. Oh, Jesus Christ.
And the shark like turned I guess
and sort of he was a firefighter,
this guy and like grazed
his leg and split.
And I think it's just the reminder that
sharks ultimately really don't want to
have anything to do with you.
I mean,
maybe hammerheads maybe a little more
aggressive. Bull Shark is the most,
because I think right, they have the most
amount of testosterone of any animal.
They're the ones that can go to the
fresh water too. Yeah. The bowls.
So they're sort of more
actively aggressive, but I
mean, I don't think a shark,
you're not good eating. I watched
the television show. They took, uh,
they found bull sharks
way up to Illinois River.
That'd be scaring whatever river it is
in Illinois. I don't know what Rivard is,
but they found him deepened freshwater.
Yeah.
These sharks make their way
all the way from the ocean.
And then Jamie d see anything
about the testosterone.
I think of any animal they
have the largest amount of
testosterone or something
like that. They're mean little
fuckers. Yeah, they are.
They're responsible for that.
Um,
the actual news incident that influenced
the creation of the movie jaws.
Oh really? Yeah. It happened in
the river in New Jersey, in Jersey.
Can imagine a river
like a freshwater river.
These people are getting
murdered by sharps look. Yeah.
Really? I didn't know that.
Yeah,
that's what it was based on the,
they didn't know that these fuckers can
swim way up into fresh water and they
just got ahold of the people got Ahold
of a few people because those buggers are
more, a little more aggressive.
Yeah. There's supposed to
be the most aggressive.
Right? Yeah. But I think, you
know, for me with the sharks,
like even jaws impacted me with
that soundtrack and I was living in,
in the Caribbean and it's a psych,
I dunno,
my kids that whenever my one daughter's
like, oh, can I get this movie on sharks?
I'm like, no, cause we live in Hawaii.
He can't be watching that stuff. Yeah.
Chuck Testosterone. Mythbusting oh,
it is scientific American. Yeah. Oh,
it's not real? No. Okay. Sound good
though. It did, didn't it? Yeah.
Much more likely to you. I'm
a bull shark, you know? Yeah.
But a tiger shark would son even
meaner? [inaudible] no. Wow.
Pools meaner than tires. Yeah. They
say Bolin hammer or more aggressive.
Then tiger layered in.
My daughter reached,
just went to do you know Mike
Mueller at all photographers sheets.
A sharks. I know who he is. Okay. He's,
he does amazing stuff,
but they go and they dive.
So he took a Reese and layered and they
went for like four days and they go in
the cage with the great whites out at the
Galapagos and they said, it's pretty
far out. You should do that sometime.
Fuck that. Commodity markets,
man fucks up the cage.
People probably doing stupid
things. No stooping. No.
He'll do things like we're guys
hit each other in the head,
but you won't go sit in a cage.
And it seems normal to me.
They said that once you see him under
that, you have a different feeling though.
Like you're not, it's not that
you're not as scared, but you,
you just see them a little differently.
Not just like a Predator, uh,
learning as you can see the pupil there,
I and everything.
Did you hear the Canada?
They're banning whale and dolphin
captivity. I think it's great.
I think it's great too, but it apparently
just passed. I mean, how about blackfish?
One documentary and it like kind of,
I think initiated a
movement. Oh, for sure. Yeah.
People didn't know they needed to do
you just see it in a digestible form
instead of having to go seek it out and
read articles about it and news reports
instead of that, they get to see it. There
it is in a very digestible format. Go,
oh my God, this is chaos. This is
horrible. This is it. This is an atrocity.
You're taking these incredible animals
that are probably some of the most
magnificent creatures that evolution has
ever created and you're putting them in
a fish tank.
You're putting them in a swimming pool.
There's their fins gold blend. Yeah.
That's crazy. Well, it actually,
if you think about the killer whale,
I mean that's,
the cane does a crazy video that I just
watched yesterday of one killing a beach
seal.
It injured the seal and the seal tried
to make it over into and it literally
beached itself smash this seal on.
There was just blood everywhere and these
a bunch of people were standing around
watching and going,
Holy Shit,
and then it flopped it's way
back into the water and swam off
it. Did it eat it? Yeah. Okay,
well that's what I mean. Listen,
that's the thing about
nature, right? It's,
it's kind of brutal but it's not
personal like the see the, the,
you know the whales not like, you know,
that seal gave me kind of a funny look.
I want to go and give it to him.
It's like, oh there's some food.
Did you ever see them one when
they're on the iceberg and they look,
oh that bugger is still holding
on and they push it again,
calves at a hunt to mark
that she was setting it up,
like showing like you can make them
slide like watch. This will slide well.
I was listening to my friend
Steve Ronell's podcast and
he was talking about the
difference in the orcas in the Puget
sound and that their local orchestras,
which are, uh, essentially, uh,
salmon specialists and
they don't eat animals,
they don't eat marine mammals.
But then there are other ones that
travel into the area and they are marine
mammals specialists. So they, all
they eat is like seals and, and uh,
and things along those lines. And they
have a totally different language.
Totally don't understand each other. They
don't interact with each other at the,
every pod has its own language.
It's crazy.
They,
they put up a whale in captivity once
and it was not eating because they didn't
know it was a seal eating well,
not a fish eating well and so learned,
I used to joke, can you imagine like,
okay, Suzy and Billy, we're
going to go watch the, you know,
the Orca Shamu and then the trainers,
they're like throwing at seal.
Like that would not work out well.
Like, Yay. Do that trick again.
Give it a slab of cute little
animal. Yeah, no, so it's a,
they're very complex. Yeah. Well it's,
if it didn't exist, it would be way more
interesting than big foot. Yeah. Right.
Everybody's like so into
big foot being real. Yeah.
Got It. I don't get big for it.
Can you talk to me about that?
Like do you think what, what is,
what's the concept of big foot?
I mean, I know, okay. It's
a big hairy guy, but yeah.
Well, I mean really come on.
What is it
most likely there was interaction between
human beings and something called the
Gi Canto Pythagoras for
thousands and thousands of years.
It's a giant bipedal hominid that it
existed in Asia that was between eight and
10 feet tall.
It was real.
And it was basically in like
the Orangutang family looks
almost orangutang like,
but enormous. And that
was a real thing. Okay.
And they didn't find out about this until
like the 1920s they found a tooth in
an apothecary shop and China and a,
and anthropologists examine this tooth.
It was like,
where the fuck did you get this?
And they took him to the site and
they dug out more things and bones and
jawbones and they
determined from the job on,
I'm sorry if I'm fucking
any of this sub scientists,
but they determined from the job
on that they think it was bipedal,
that it stood up on two legs
and so then they said, well,
how big would this thing be?
And then in the proportionate,
yeah, like the fields. Are you ever seen
one? A real one looks like? Yeah. I just,
sometimes I, when they say like,
oh up in Michigan, I'm like,
is it really like what are they seeing?
Bullshit.
Most of it is the people seeing shadows
in the trees and they want to believe
it's big foot and they're seeing
bears that are walking on two legs.
But if there was a thing,
what's really interesting is that's
where it would be because if it did come
across the larynx, the Bering land
bridge, like they believe humans did.
If that did happen, the many animals
Maton navigated from there to here.
That way.
That's where Alaska and
the Pacific northwest,
that would be the natural path.
And then if you think about how
densely wooded that area is, right,
that would be a natural habitat for
something that's hiding from people.
The problem is you can only hide from
shit anymore. It's just too hard.
They'd see from space something
would catch you on a trail camera.
Some, there's trail cameras that
are everywhere. They're fork like,
did you see those?
These a guy and his father got caught
poaching a mother bear in her den.
It's ill,
it's horrific,
it's horrible and it's not
just horrible because they,
they poached this mother bear in there,
Dan and left the,
the baby's essentially to die,
but they were talking about
how they're not going
to get caught doing it.
Like no one's going to tie us to this.
And the way they were caught,
there was a four k camera that
was right behind them that was,
that was observing this,
this whole area where
this bear was den den.
They have these trail cameras now that
are incredibly accurate. There's so like,
it's so high definition.
Super Clear and the audio is clear.
They would catch one of
those fucking things. Yeah.
If there was something out there,
but I think there is something to
be said for the tooth fairy and
thinking we don't know everything like
that. It's fun. The magic of stuff,
unknown and behind. I mean for me it
doesn't have to be big flip, but I love,
I love the idea that we haven't seen
everything. We don't know everything.
Obviously we know that
with space and who knows,
you know and dimensions
and time and universe.
But something mythical is pretty fun.
Well,
what's interesting is that there was
a bunch of different kinds of humans.
That's what's interesting. And they
found these bones and Russia that,
I think they call them the
dentist's Whovians, they found a,
but this is within the last 10 15 years,
they found a completely different
species of humans that lived in Russia.
They found those little people on the
island of Flores and that was only like 10
years ago.
I mean there's,
there's probably dozens more that
they just haven't uncovered somewhere.
So if there was at one point Tom,
some big giant hominid it's
totally possible. Yeah.
I just don't think he would have to
eat so much to be alive. 10 today.
Beef constantly. It's like
a bear, like you find bear
shit everywhere. Where's the,
where's the gorilla shit, the big foot
shit or whatever it is. It's an easy,
is it eating plants? Is it eating
animals? What the fuck is it?
Eating right can eat a lot.
A lot.
That's in big family of a
six foot something husband
at home and he, it's a lot,
a lot about all surfing all day
that that Duke could put it down.
He can put it down. Can you eat a
lot? A lot. I preposterous amounts,
foods and ideally big each meal or do you
started got okay, dinner and today, Hey,
what's your big nouns is white. How
are you feeling? Yeah, it depends.
Like sometimes I've
giant meals for dinner,
but sometimes if I worked out too hard
at night I'll have a giant breakfast.
If I just,
I just do whatever I feel like doing,
but I definitely always have intermittent
fasting. It's at least six days a week.
I take 16 hours off one day.
I don't give a fuck.
It's amazing how much food we don't
really need to. Yeah, it is amazing.
I used to eat way too much in like way
too much protein and stuff when I was
playing and going through
different phases of training. Um,
now do you go into like autophagy
and do all that tail? No. Oh, okay.
No one explained that to
people. Um, yeah. Well yeah,
it just one sort of step,
a bigger alist a deeper step when you,
when you do a little bit intermittent
fasting is if you don't start the
digestive process. So if you just
had, you can have water and caffeine,
you can't have fats and things like that.
Um,
the theory is is that
whatever soul, uh, you know,
dysfunction you have, you kind of can
rinse out kind of three times the amount,
the process of when you
do intermittent fasting.
So it can be a really effective way when
you're in a minute fasting to say, okay,
I'm going to pick this four
hour window for most people,
probably be between like three and seven
or two and six and I'm going to eat.
And then the rest of the time I'm not
going to, so it's, it's very close.
It's just sort of one more twist they can
put on it. I think it's like a t o p o,
you know, so that's a 20 hour
fast food window every day. Yeah.
And I have a friend who was doing
it pretty regularly and he used to,
he looked different. Really?
Yeah, please. Yeah, no he did.
He shifted his body composition a
little bit and um, it was interesting.
And there's some interesting data.
I'm sure Jamie can give you the
download on it. Um, yeah, autophagy,
it's just sorta like one notch
higher. It's not fun. But I, you know,
like for me it would have to be kind of,
I would want to eat between one and five.
I could do without it the rest of the
time. Um, and you can have, like I said,
caffeine and water.
It's incredible what a
poll mouth pleasure has.
Like my kids bought these estimates,
cupcakes.
They're those humans that's like old
school, old school, but they are bullshit.
These cupcakes,
they're like those
chocolate frosting on top,
a little whites, Quigley. And the inside
is a cream filled. God Damn was delicious.
But while I was eating and I was like,
what the fuck are you eating man?
This is all nonsense. You shouldn't
even be touching this. No.
Well you can't do that.
I think once you,
cause we pretty strict Laird's have
a little more strict than I am. Um,
I think if you're going to eat that
cupcake, you enjoy it. Yep. I think,
you know,
even having that small conversation with
yourself as a colossal waste of time,
as you shove it in your mouth
and it goes down, it's like,
because that's so human, right? Like,
it's like, I shouldn't be doing this,
but here I go, you know, why am I doing,
why I shouldn't? You know, it's like,
I think it's important to do
it and enjoy it. But yeah,
that's not food that's like,
I don't know what that is.
The thing can live for like 800 years
thing is we had eaten and I was full,
but that looks so good.
Like if someone had cut a piece of steak
and put it in front of me, I'd be like,
I'm good. I'm sorry I'm stuck.
I saw that cupcake. I was like,
look at that motherfucker that when
kids are like, I can't eat anymore.
What's for dessert?
I have a separate space for that.
That doesn't change because we're older.
I still have a separate space. It's just,
you know,
try not to use it so much when they
say that for people that are in like
competitive eating
competitions too though,
you can still eat fries because fries
or you don't like fries. You'd be like,
I just had the vision of a guy shoving
it in the water and then the Bun and the
hot dog and then like, you know,
squeezing it down. Yeah, yeah.
That you can eat fries. Cause what?
It's not protein. No, it's uh,
it's the saltiness and the, the,
the, the carbs. You could still eat,
you can always eat another car.
He'll give, you ate a steak. Right.
And that steak was a big 18 ounce
ribeye. You ate the whole thing like, oh,
but then you see those fries,
like all three of those fries
and deployments of Ketchup. Aw.
There you could keep eating,
you can eat another thousand calories
when you're in that food, like a trance,
you getting those food trends. Food
trances. Yeah. I mean you have people,
I have friends that like, you know, if you
have any like thing out on the counter,
that snack ish, like you
have it for the kids. Right.
And your friends that come to visit and
say hi and they're kind of fidgety and
all of a sudden they were just like eating
everything and you look at him like,
Bro, like you're in a constant
food. They like Trans Snack.
It like don't have snacky, you know,
anything around is can't help themselves.
Oh No. CanNot for sure. No,
I, but I find it easier.
I don't know if you found it easier.
Like I had a,
I used to have a really
heavy chocolate trip heavy.
Like I used to have a chocolate drawer,
like the whole thing, like no for real,
like every kind of chocolate, like get
open it. And it wasn't like a thin door.
It wasn't like a silverware with drawer.
It was like a deep drawer.
Every kind of chocolate
and I mean stress,
you have bus out the
chocolate, you know, whatever.
Right before your time
chocolate kid walks in the room,
they've taken something and you're
like chocolate. You know. So I'd had,
I had every kind and work it does,
but then I stopped eating it as much and
now it's like I don't even really want
it as as much. It's weird.
It's kind of a bummer.
Really love dark chocolate
with peanut butter. Oh yeah.
Like some dark chocolate pudding
to try it on their jiffy. Oh yeah.
Some skippy and be some bullshit peanut
butter. I like the crunchy stuff too.
So yeah, because the healthy stuff,
somehow the oil and the stuff is separate.
You need that stuff that has like those
unknown chemicals to make it really
smooth. If you like this natural peanut
butter, this isn't good. It's not smooth.
Look at that
natural peanut butter.
You got to get that
fucking butter sandwich,
school lunch that you rip a hole in the
bride your life to knowing. Yeah, no,
forget it. It's either too dry or
too oily. Yeah, it doesn't work.
It's never perfect. You can't make a
sandwich with it. There's just no way.
You got to commit to a five minutes
stir before you ever even think about
putting that shit on your
bread. Absolutely. Hey, so
you know what I was thinking,
I wanted to invite you.
You can bring whoever you want to come
pull train with us with pool training.
What do you guys do
Jamie?
Can you pull up like a pool
training or XPT pulled training.
P T was that Sam for, this is another
thing that we do, but this kid,
this is like a 12 year old former
training. We built this pool and layered,
you know it's always trying to, you
know, athletes in their off season and
we were like his crap.
Like six of our friends.
We built this huge pool
and there it's like, okay,
take some dumbbells and go down
a, there's Kyle Kingsbury. Yeah,
you're big way anywhere. Says t
his little suit, the little girl to
do it. And uh, anyway, this
is all the shallow stuff,
but there's deep water. That
girl didn't get going. Um,
they have dumbbells in their
crotches we'll get Kyle,
this is when he was a little bigger.
Stoia do we have the idea of how,
okay,
so there's deep water. Like you're
13 feet, you have w you have weights,
ballistic,
um,
ballistic training. No. Uh,
no punishment to your joints and doing
cleans in the ocean or in the pool
rather. Yeah, I don't,
this is all shallow.
There's some deep water stuff and I'm
not sure why that guy is doing a little,
did you drop the Dumbo
all the way down to the,
so you have drag and stuff like that.
And also it's lighter in the water and
heavier out. But this is not the stuff,
I mean this is all good. It increases
your lung capacity and things like that.
But there is a deep water element where
so you can be ballistic and you can do
all this stuff and um,
you don't pound your joints
and you can get stronger.
So we have a lot of athletes that come
and train so that they can sort of work
on some of these elements of there
being more dynamic or what have you.
You're in compression. It's, it's
pretty cool. And we couple it.
So I know you like to do heat and stuff,
so we'll do like heat and ice and then
pool and heat and ice and pool and things
like that. It's, it's pretty great and
you're tired but you're not beat up.
George Saint Pierre actually did a lot
of that in training for his last fight.
He did a lot of his work.
Here's the deeper stuff I see.
So you can like,
and what's cool about this too is,
um,
is that you have to moderate your breath
because it's very straight forward air,
no air, air nowhere. And
just listening to this,
we're looking at these guys.
It's probably like a nine foot pool.
They have dumbbells in their hands that
drop all the way down to the bottom and
then let their knees go to full, full, uh,
bend and then with their butt to their
heels and then jump right back up and pop
out of the water, get a deep breath,
and then go right back down again.
So you're constantly leaping through
the water to go to the surface.
Yeah,
the skin ripples.
So I actually think it's really
attractive when you're a girl too.
I just want to tell you what's
crazy is that, think about this.
I actually think so. You're
in compression, so you've
got those benefits, right.
And I think your tissue,
like your fashion,
everything gets kind of rolled almost
in every, every set with that ripple.
I think so. And, and that they're
more shallow and then there's more,
there's deeper and things like that.
But there's probably about 35
exercises that we've come up with.
Laird made us all his crash
test dummies. Um, but it,
it will economy makes you feel like
1 million bucks, but you can Kinda,
you can bust your butt on
it. Right. But you don't,
you're not getting in the pounding. Well
that's it. I already have a fake knee.
Yeah. What'd you blow it out? Uh,
well it was an ongoing since my
twenties and then finally at 46 I got it
replaced. Wow. Is the difference now? Ah,
so much better. I was like, yeah,
I used to like sleep with my good leg
underneath my knee trying to open my knee
joint because it felt like metal on like
hot metal touching and then your foot
gets heavy, you know, if you lose
a lot of your, your function.
I tried everything,
you know like stem cell and PRP and like
you try everything because you don't
want to be like getting a fake knee.
And then after I was like,
I'm sure there'll be
something better in 10 years,
but right now let's just do it. So it
was, we went in the same day. We actually,
Larry got his hip done the same
day and I got my knee done.
How did Willard injuries hip
repetitive trauma, I mean,
you know,
Laird is now 55 he was
52 when he got his hip.
And he's, he's tough on his body.
I mean, he's tough on his body.
And then if you're like
doing isometric loading,
when the foiling that one hips taking a
head, it's the back leg. It's, you know,
it's a lot,
a lot of load.
It's amazing though that he's gotten
back to surfing at the same level.
It's, he's, he's very
unique. You know, he,
you know, he says that everything he does,
like his relationships, what he reads,
what he eats,
um,
what he spends time doing is
all to enhance him to perform.
And his, you know, a ton of people like
this, his ability to deal with discomfort,
he has a very good relationship
with discomfort. So his
training and stuff, it's,
you know,
wow. Those guys wind up
injuring themselves because
of the though that mental
toughness.
But he's really smart. He's not a, well,
you're not his age and foolhardy. He's
not like want to show it. I can do.
He's a guy who can call it. He's a guy who
can go, yeah, no, it's not a good idea.
So when they do the hip,
they have to put that that raw through
the center of the hip and then put the
new joint on the outside.
It's all, I mean he
walked, he stayed awake.
They did a local and he left the
hospital at three o'clock that day. Wow.
It's carpentry.
They whack out the doctor huge
that it's not fine surgery.
It's like carpentry and he stayed awake
cause the guy's like, okay, you can,
you can handle it, you know, the noise or,
or whatever.
He uh,
same time.
And then he was gone
out out of the hospital.
How long did it take to rehabilitate?
Not Long. I mean he was,
once the incision closed, he could go
out in the water. What's that? 10 days?
Sure. Pretty cool. That's crazy
that they can do that now.
I had a buddy who did that,
Graham Hancock.
He did the six weeks later he was
here and he told me after we were,
he was walking around, I was saying hi
to him. Was that I had my hip replaced.
So I go when he was six weeks ago.
What the fuck are you talking about?
You're just walking.
You just don't want to play golf.
You walk out of the hospital.
Okay. Bad thing. Well, let's say if
you were loading your
hip that you load into,
you might want to not do that right
away. It sounds weird, but yeah. Yeah.
Like you'd put weird torque on it.
Yeah.
I know a guys have gotten back to
Jujitsu with bad hips. Oh yeah.
Back to rolling and training again.
It's,
you know what they basically tell you
is you don't want to do anything you
wouldn't want to do with your real joint.
Like the guys like Sophie
ever got into a car accident.
You wouldn't want your knees to go back
and in towards your hip. It's like, okay,
well I don't think I'd want that
to happen with my natural hip.
So I think they're pretty good. Is it
significantly weaker? No, not at all.
Not at all. No. Do basically everything.
He can do everything. Wow. That's crazy.
And he had a pretty wicked limp.
The two of us were limping around for
like two years. It was really cool.
People are like, Hey, you guys
are those like athletes, right?
That a couple of them were like
hobbling around. We're like, yeah,
stay right there. We'll be right there. It
was just like brutal. Our kids are like,
what are you going to do? Like I'm
just going to run away, you know,
a way I stop it right there. You know,
what can you do now with your knee?
Can you do all the things
that used to be able to do?
It would be a bummer for Jujitsu guys
cause kneeling is kind of not the best.
Like if he said, give me 1 million
bucks cash right now, child's pose.
I bet that's tough. Yeah,
that's tough. What part hurts?
Uh, I think for me it's also part
of my bio mechanics that, uh,
the tissue on my, uh, um,
my quads is like probably like beef
jerky from jumping all those years.
So that's something I'm always working on.
Um,
so maybe a more flexible person going
in would have more mobility in that bent
position. But it just, you know, you
get a hard finish on it on the joint.
But I think it's pretty
amazing what you can do.
Like it's pretty far out.
Can you sidestep and stuff like that.
I could play volleyball if I wanted to.
You can jump and land and be hard on it.
And Joey do pliers and stuff.
Yeah.
So they basically say just do stuff that
you would do normally with your knee.
Yeah, I mean, yes B be intelligent.
Like you probably wouldn't want to go
all I'm an ultra marathon or now. Right.
Cause you might wear your joint out in
like two years. But I think if you said,
I really like to run but I'll go on
the grass or the sand barefoot probably
better stuff like that. But that's what
you want to do again anyway. You know,
running s pretty tough on Ya. Yeah.
And it's not just tough on your knees.
It's tough on your back
and stuff and everything.
Are you wearing on a hard surface,
seven times your body weight, right.
Like each step, I mean,
unless you're built,
like when you see those people that
are built to run, it's perfect. Yeah.
So that was,
that was sort of,
I think that's what's interesting
about being when you see people go, Oh,
I'm an athlete and, and then it's
like, and some days I feel, I don't,
I'm sure you feel this way.
It's like I feel so unathletic or so,
uh,
banged up or you know,
like I have friends that came
into training late and everything,
all their joints are like
all perfect and you know,
they work perfectly in and sometimes I,
I've, I've felt a little bit beat up.
Laird been beat up a lot, but he, he kind
of trains his way out of it. Big Time.
Now when you guys are on coal,
why,
is there a lot of resources in terms
of like places to train or physical
therapists or any of that kind of stuff?
No, I think the other islands,
like a Wahoo and Maui, they
would certainly have it.
I was, I actually, um, this group
that owns this business there,
let me use a warehouse and
I taught a class three days
a week for free, a dollar.
Um, so they were covered under my
insurance because we have so little, uh,
training like we have, we have
access, we have a gem and stuff,
but like the community on the north
didn't really, so I started, uh,
doing that like three days a week to get
people, there was like a hundred of us.
Oh, that's the same time it was,
it was really cool. Uh, but,
but because they don't have stuff to,
they don't have really great facilities.
What a weird place to live. Is it,
it's kind of bad, but don't you think?
Like when I go to New
York City with layered,
he looks there and he looks at
the buildings and he's like,
why do people do this to themselves?
Like, we've gotten twisted around like,
you're like Hawaii, what a weird
place to live. But in a way,
it's probably closer to how
we're meant to live, you know,
stacked up on top of each
other. But having said that, um,
yeah. Compared to other parts of
the world, I mean in its remote,
like you're out there, it's,
I think besides Easter island,
it's like the most remote
place in the world. Wow. Yeah.
Really that's interesting. But it makes
sense. Yeah, it's far. I mean, you know,
they navigated their,
and they said that the water sea level
was lower so that they could see more
land when the Polynesian sailed there.
But it's pretty,
uh, it's a pretty interesting
contrast to living in Malibu,
let's say. But then in a way, not because
you're surrounded by nature, right?
Yeah.
I think it's probably a far more
healthy way to live. I just,
I just know that a lot of
people do get that island fever,
they can't take it and they
want to get the fuck off.
Yeah. And like if when you have a
family, like when our kids were young,
it's like you're doing the same thing.
You're taking them places.
You are making dinners,
you're making lunches.
So in a way you're just doing sort of
everyday things in a really pretty place.
And also you probably
live a little simpler.
It's gotta be better for you in terms
of like the amount of stress that you
experience and the beauty of nature's
very calming and soothing and probably
therapeutic and beneficial.
Yeah. But it's that reminder. I
mean, this has been thing for me.
It's like you could have all that
at your access, but if you're not,
if you haven't dealt with
yourself or you're not, if
you're feel miserable, um, it,
it sort of doesn't really matter.
And I think that that kind of
place points it out really quick,
where when you live in a busy place,
you can distract yourself from
yourself and you can be like, oh,
there's traffic and I have stuff to
do and I'm busy. I'm a busy person,
I'm at an office, I Delta stock. And
when you're there, you can't blame
really the traffic. You can, you
sort of have to go, oh, that's right.
So it's an interesting thing of
when we talk about like health or,
or beautiful places and things like that,
it's still always comes
back to yourself and like,
am I, have I made myself happy? Um,
am I doing things that make me feel good?
Things like that.
So I think what's really great about
that places that gets clear real quick.
Did you guys have real internet out there?
Totally like legit and I mean we had
dial up til about 18 months ago for real.
No, but I mean do you
have high speed or nodes?
Like it is America for like
five genius or whatever.
They've got that blanket over us there
but it isn't the mind control five g net
or whatever.
Everybody's worried about that.
I know I have a friend
freaking out about it.
Five g well we did Rudy. Something
about they do have the ability to,
it does have an effect on human brains,
but that's what I mean. It's like pretty,
pretty serious. We're going to do
ourselves in one day with innovation.
We're going to keep going.
Absolutely.
One day we've well fucked ourselves
sideways. That's the way that it,
it goes right?
Like you get so smart that you evolve.
You're like check the I when I was a
kid we had a mad magazine and I'll never
forget it.
I was like 11 years old and there was
a s a sketch of this explosion in space
and it was like two aliens talking and
they were looking at at this explosion,
you know, millions of miles
away. And they go, oh,
they said smart beings lived
there, you know, pretty much,
I mean I think that in a way that we're,
we're probably,
I mean we do a lot with water
and air and things like that,
but it is interesting to see,
I'm always fascinated that
people will do stuff for money.
Like guys like guys running
companies and they go, well,
it's okay about the pollution or
the byproduct and you go, yeah,
but your kids or your
grandkids are going to like,
money's not going to protect you
from if the climate goes bizarre.
Yeah. But they feel like someone else
can fix that. They go to get this money.
He thinks that money. Yeah. I think
that's just a compartmentalization.
They just don't, don't think about the,
also, they're a part of a corporation.
Right. And everybody just does their
little task. But it does trip me out.
Like she'd go like, you know, we say
the rain falls on everyone's house.
Like it's coming for everybody, no
matter how much cheese you have. Well,
it's also the fact that we've had on it.
It has been over this window of a hundred
years long and it's a massive effect.
I mean, unbelievably massive
effect on the environment.
It's just a short window of
time. In terms of, you know,
when you, I'm sure you saw Jiro dreams
of Sushi. Yeah, of course. Yeah.
When they're sitting around talking about
the fish markets back in the day we'd
get so much more tuna.
Like you look one day it's fished out.
This is one year alive man.
So when this guys in during his lifetime
and went from abundance of tuna to
being almost fished out. Yep. And they're
not slowing down sushis everywhere.
It's like,
I know what
we'd done in 30 years is pretty
far out. It's crazy. I know. It's,
I know it's an I,
it's funny cause my kids,
I don't know if you see this
with your kids, it's like,
I think they're pretty aware
of it. Um, and they, uh,
I think that they go flip and flop
between feeling like the adults are poorly
behaved and they're left of the pile of,
you know,
of our bad decisions.
And also like my one daughter's like is,
do you think it'd be okay to be like
a militant environmentalist? You know,
and she's like six feet tall. And
I'm like, that'd be fantastic.
Sea Shepherd on steroids. It's like,
you know, you know, so I think,
uh, it's going to be
interesting to see, you know,
what the next group because
they're obviously really different.
Like they don't want big giant houses
and all that stuff that, you know,
sort of my generation and your generation
thought that's what you think the new
generation is different in their values
and what they find is important,
right?
They, they give more, they volunteer more.
I think the tricky thing for them is going
to be connection and being able to be
connected and being able to
have a real conversation and uh,
you know, even be able to
concentrate long enough to,
to be with somebody because of devices.
Yeah. I mean, I think it's far.
Could you imagine right
now if you were 20 no.
And being like dating and swiping
and trying to pay attention and
10,
you know my daughter,
one of the few girls in her
closet doesn't have a cell phone.
What's the age that do they get?
I'm like,
I've had them since they were like
seven. No, I mean you're a kid.
Like what's the rule in your house?
There's a debate right now trying
to figure it out. Well, okay,
so you have a 10 year
old going to be 11 yeah.
I think that they say there's
like a movement. Wait til eighth.
Yeah. You heard that you had like 10
kids in the class. All the parents agree.
So they're not the only person in
the class that doesn't have it,
but it's not that way with my daughter's
kids. They're kids in her class.
Most of them have phones.
Most parents just give the
kid a phone. Yeah. It's just,
um,
there's a,
have you read any of Jonathan hates stuff?
The coddling of the
American media of course.
And that that has just so disturbing
when you see the amount of,
especially young girls that
are growing up, depressed,
cutting themselves self harm.
What's that like 400% he said like from
10 to 14 or something crazy like that.
Like something insane.
Massive spike that directly coincides
with the invention of smartphones and
social media. Yeah,
the slot machine. Yeah.
It's this this thing where people were
just trying to get likes and trying to
leverage their,
you know,
their social status and and try to
pretend that they're living in a perfect
world to everybody around
them and everyone else is
doing it and people look at
other people's lives being perfect
and they reflect upon their own.
They get depressed.
There's just so many factors that kids
didn't have to deal with just to a decade
or so ago. It's really, really off.
Right.
Like at least if I had a hard time at
school I could go home and have a reprieve
from it at least overnight.
I think for me that's been a
thing with my kids is like,
cause especially daughters,
I do think I understand the gaming
is different for boys and porn,
pornography and things like that and not
whole trip of rewiring their brain. And,
but I think with girls it's like
how do you get them to under
like get hear their own voice?
I don't know how they're going to get to
a place where they, I mean cause every,
it's like this weird
mishmosh of like me too.
And then never before had people objectify
themselves more because they get that
positive affirmation. Like I always say,
if I put out really smart ideas, um,
if I'm a young woman,
oh I have a thousand followers,
every shot is of my,
but I have 10 million followers.
So we have this mixed message going on,
which is like,
I'm angry me to treat me
equal simultaneously to,
I'm going to objectify myself in the most
hardcore way more than in any time in
history.
And I talked to the results and it's
really blow it blow for me as a female
who's, who understands both
those sides a little bit. Um, I,
it kind of trips me out because I
don't think you like those girls,
you know, playing that card and have
no violence should be done to you.
And I agree with all of that
and no is no and all of that.
But at a certain point,
you know,
like you've had Jordan
Peterson on here many times.
It's like biological signaling.
It's like w w like play a side at least.
And also that, oh, that's, that
one side is super short lived.
That's what I tried to tell my girls. I'm
like, Yo, listen, if you're, you know,
you're pretty girls,
it's great,
but if that's the card you're
playing your cards done,
like by the time you're 30, 35,
it's done. It's over. Um, you know,
unless you're like 40 and you marry a
seven year old, I don't know, whatever,
the MILF porn, is that
such a thing? Yeah. Yeah.
But even that, it's like they've
got to put a filter on it.
And I'm like all that stuff. I
mean come on. You know what I mean?
It's like at a certain point,
how do you get these girls to go,
hey stand up for yourself. Be
Strong. But like what are you doing?
But look at all these people that are
not doing that. They're are benefiting.
I know but it's getting them to understand
how do you get a 13 year old to talk
about the long game?
Yeah,
I mean everything's immediate but for
me it's like it's culturally I feel like
I'm this weird mix of like the most,
I came through it the most modern time.
Like women went to school on
scholarships and like we, we,
there was no thought to being
like strong. Not really. And then,
but then weirdly it's like I feel so kind
of old fashion when I see kind of this
next thing cause I'm like well strong.
For me,
it was something else strong was like
you were really physically strong trying
to have a strong mind,
you know,
strong basis of a person and then okay,
then there was this other side, like your,
your sexuality, all this other stuff.
And now it's like, I don't know, I,
it's very interesting,
right?
Well there's certainly a bunch of
different kinds of people, right?
And there's going to be people that
gravitate towards objectifying themselves
and this kind of people that gravitate
in this day and age towards, you know,
you see a lot of people's pages are
just fill with motivational quotes and
inspirational things and you know,
and then the stories about people that
they meet and photos and you get a lot of
people that are attracted to that
kind of stuff too. It's just,
you're not going to get the immediate
gratification of a picture of your ass
that that picture of your ass
gets 100,000 likes. Like, wow,
look at all those likes.
And then, you know,
it's just a different vibe and
you have to decide what do you,
after you have to quantity or quality
or after you are trying to accurately
express how you feel and,
and work it out through communicating
with people and figure out how they react
to what you're saying and how you feel
about how other people say similar things
and how it does good things for you.
And you want to do good things for them.
Or do you just want to have a piece of
dental floss up the crack of your ass
sticking it in front of
the camera? This, you know?
No, and I, I get that. Like
I get also, like I always say
when you're a young woman,
you sort of get this new car and
you're like, well, what happens?
Like what if I put my foot on the gas?
Like you're sort of checking it all out.
Like who they respond like this if I do
that, like that's completely natural.
But then at a certain point, um, I
don't know that the input is like,
uh, you know, like, who do you want to be?
And not based on what
everyone thinks about you,
like what actually turns you on and s
and s makes you feel excited and stoked
because you know it's great
that you have a nice butt,
but there's a lot of Nice butts and in
the end that's not probably going to
bring you that other feeling.
The problem is that there's a thrill
to positive reaction. Absolutely.
And that thrills undeniable. I
would like it. I'm just too old
people. And when people get that
thrill and you tell them, hey,
that thrills bad for you.
You look fuck off mom.
No, no, I mean a bolt onto
that message. How about that?
Like get the thrill but
simultaneously to doing the thrill.
Maybe have some other
thoughts about where you,
where you like to continue to journey too.
I think when you tell
that to a 13 year old,
the here and eventually I think in
the beginning of the like gay, yeah,
I got this.
And then later when it all goes sideways,
like God damn wish to listen to mom.
I think you just got to be it too and
have some like cool friends that hang
around you because you're, if
you're the parent it's like, okay,
you're going to penetrate so much.
But if you've got some like you know
in Hawaii they call them aunties.
If he got some Badass chicks around you
and your daughters are looking, they see,
they say,
but what if you don't have access to that?
I have a lot of pretty strong,
cool women around me,
but I could not that it concerns me.
I don't want to say that.
It's just how to you help the next group,
you know,
try to be a good example.
Love on them,
but get them to teach them to
love on themselves. That's all.
And I don't mean,
yeah,
with eyelash extensions and perfect
things. I mean like love on yourself,
you know?
Well that's the other thing too.
This is a distortion distortion
of natural beauty and you know,
make it so that everything has to be
artificial. The color of your lips,
the color of your eye, shadow, fake
lashes, everything is just this,
that doesn't, doesn't look better.
Just looks different. Do you think I,
I'm always fascinated what men
think like today, even like do they,
does it even register? Do they
know what's going on? In what way?
Well, I guess we'd have to ask men of
that generation if, let's say they had,
uh,
two groups of women and one that was
like perfectly quaffed with the lip
injection. And is it,
I like that I'm talking about like eyelash
extension is one of the Joe, but, um,
like just sort of really done like
ready for the club, let's just say.
And then just like a girl,
like, hi, I'm a, you know,
I'm a sweaty runner and now I'm going to
go to the office and put my hair up in
a ponytail. I don't know what
her, if guys, if they even,
can they tell the difference?
I mean, it's all what you're
in, what your entails.
Some guys just like,
um,
soft and made up some guys
like I'm sweaty and muscular.
Yeah, still. And I get all
that. I love that. I just mean,
again, it's hardcore signaling and I
guess that's, maybe that's what it is.
Maybe it's the new biology.
Well,
it's also that there's never been a time
like I that a bit on one of my Netflix
specials were about this girl
who's got just pictures of her ass.
She was like 9 million followers
on Instagram. I'm like,
there's never been a
person like this before.
This is a new kind of person like fuck,
fuck.
Looking at these frogs in the Amazon
that no one's going to say there's a new
kind of person.
This girl just has pictures of her butt
and she's got millions of people staring
at her all day long and every
day is just new pictures of her,
but it's a great point. I always am
intrigued how they decide like, oh,
we're going to do the but on the beach
now let's do the button next to the puppy.
It's like, I'm so confused
how they keep getting ideas.
I can't even get ideas for different
things and it's like, I know we'll do,
but with the cotton candy it's like,
okay, I don't know why he's got that.
I think it becomes an obsession.
I mean,
I think you have to stay
fresh with new bud ideas.
Is that envelope take my editor
head editor here@but.com I don't know.
But if you have a girl who has,
let's say some of these girls have
millions and millions of followers and
they're making millions of
dollars are crushing it.
Maybe they're actually the smartest
people in the room and I haven't caught on
yet.
It's certainly an easy path to finances.
And I know if you have a great ass and
you're like working out and you just want
to take pictures
of it and all of sudden you have
25 million followers, like damn,
but this goes also okay,
what she do quit that job.
Definitely not cause then
when is she going to say,
well I'll do the right thing and work at
the library. I'm not saying it's just,
I mean if it was my kid, I'd
be like, you know, sweetie,
you might want to weigh out
the economics on this. Right?
I think you said something
really important.
It's a whole new thing
and I think however,
it's sort of like the communication.
You're always having, which is well,
what is success? And
for me it's, that's all.
It's like getting people,
encouraging them, whatever that is,
whatever that looks like.
You know,
you said this like Oh you do the show
whether anyone was listening or not most
likely, right? I mean until you couldn't
afford it anymore, let's just say.
But obviously I would do it just
to have the conversations, right.
Maybe I wouldn't do it as much,
but I would definitely do it if I,
like if someone said, hey, you know,
every few months a physicists will come
in here and sit down with you for three
hours about,
yeah let's do it.
Yeah. Well you're bringing information
to you and learning to you. So for you,
part of your definition,
that success.
And so I guess that is the conversation
cause we always have this thing that's
obvious thing of like successes. It
either his notoriety, it's power,
it's money and then we forget those other
communications about like the pursuit
of something that really
genuinely turns you on.
Well I think people get short sided
and you definitely can get success.
We just have money.
And you just have objects and you have
notoriety and people view it as success.
But if you're not doing what you love,
it's not pure success.
It's a different kind of success.
Like if you really find something that
you enjoy doing and then you take that
like layered has with surfing or many
people have with their passions and then
you become successful through that. It's
a different existence because it's an,
it's a pure existence.
Like when I do stand up comedy or if I
do see like a commentary for the UFC,
it's uh, a very, it's a pure enthusiasm.
It's genuine and I don't have to
fake it. It's, I enjoy doing it.
That's to me, I don't, I know
everybody can't do that. No.
Or everybody feels like they can't do
that or they haven't figured out a way to
do that yet. Right. But if you can, if you
can, if there's a thing that you can do,
like maybe I would have made more
money if I went into the stock market.
Maybe have made more money if I was
a banker. Maybe. I don't know. Right.
But I definitely wouldn't be as happy.
There's no way.
If I'm the same person I am now and
I was in a fucking office all day,
making a hundred times as much money,
I'd be miserable.
Right.
And I think that,
I guess for me that's maybe when I see
the thing with the girls and like I said,
feeling sensitive to it because I have
daughters or just young people in general.
It's that conversation of like,
you know,
just keeping that definition of
success open. And by the way,
this other path that taking it,
like following your own
instincts or desires or passions,
there's elements to that that are,
our heart are harder for sure.
It's more unknown. You can feel insecure.
Like is this the right thing to do?
I mean we've gone,
I mean in our house we've gone through
that 50 different times, you know,
it's like I'm going to do
this cause I really want to,
I don't know what's going to happen.
Right.
And I don't know if it's going to be
successful. I might even lose money.
Who knows?
But that once you start to do
it or you do it once or twice,
then you go, oh, but it's so worth trying.
If you can pull it off.
That's the thing.
Like if everything worth
doing is hard to do,
do everything and,
but by the way you might pursue,
we've pursued 10 businesses
and like one is soup,
really thriving, two are doing
well and the rest like we ate it,
we ate it in cash, we
ate it in time, we did.
So I think that's the other thing
that's important is like, Hey, uh,
you know, it's like sports.
How many times, you know,
do you lose to you? You lose a lot.
Um, in order to win. And I think,
I think that's something that for me,
like with my girls it's like,
hey, just try to work really
hard and hear your own voice and,
and follow that if you can. And
it is scary. I think it's scary.
We are also a person who's
had that opinion reinforce
through vigorous work over
the years. I mean your,
your uh, your, uh, your, uh,
super successful competitive athlete,
which is one of the most difficult
things for a person to do,
to like force your body to perform
better than everybody else's.
Figure a way to win,
figure a way to get points scored figure
way where all these other people who
are also high level athletes are
trying to stop you from doing it,
figuring out a way to succeed
and you're going to fucking fail.
There's no way around it.
You're going to have ups and downs,
but you're gonna understand the value
of pursuit of dedication and discipline
and your kids are going to see that.
It's like they,
they must know their mom is a bad ass.
No, I don't know. Kind of
understand who you are. Yes and no.
I think it's interesting cause then
you know like how sons can push against
Dad's dad's identities,
right? Sure. There's times,
not my youngest and last,
my oldest,
but my middle went through a phase
where it was like, she was almost like,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna Knock her off her high horse,
a know like my,
my real estate that I,
that was my real estate. And it's
like, um, and you know, she's a big,
strong kid and, but then she, I think
she realized like, oh no, no, no,
this is more about me
finding my own real estate.
Like my mom did that because that was
what my mom had to do and what she was
good at. And that was my thing. And it
was, but there was a minute that I think,
listen, no kid looks at their parent
that they actually live with by the way,
and is like, yeah, they're
cool. There's just no,
I mean, like if I deserted them and called
like four times a year, they'd be like,
it's my mom. She's on the phone and she's
an exotic country. They're like, Yo,
get me some water. I'm going to
bed. Like, you know, it's like,
it's no different in any
house. And by the way, I,
I have this new thing I'm doing right
now with my youngest daughter cause she
can get me, like, she can get
me like nobody's business.
Like Laird always jokes,
he goes, you two are not allowed to
drive in the car together anymore.
Like we come home from one ride from
school and I'm on the mats. Right.
This kid is like, cause we're very
similar and she just works me.
And then she work. He was just you
and her alone of course. Oh No.
Especially she's no dummy. This
kid is so smart. We always joke,
I like Brody will run something. I
just want her to have friends. Uh,
hopefully you know that she's,
she's pretty radical and she always gives
you this look to while she's carving
you up. That took a slight
smirk on her face and I'm like,
I'm gonna kill this kid. You know? And
so, and then you think I'm, I'm, you know,
I'm, I've been around, I'm trying to be
evolved and I don't think I'm having a,
you know, insulin spike. Like
I should be balanced and calm.
I think I meditated this morning and
I'm like four seconds. And I'm like,
you know,
the console
becomes a little sport for
him too. Yeah. So now, okay,
so this is the best is so I go,
okay.
I layered was telling me
this story years ago, he got,
he went down a river raft down a river
and went down the rapids and got pinned
against the rock.
Okay.
And it was breaking on his back and
he said he was pushing on the rock and
pushing, couldn't get off. Okay.
And he said he had this image of like
a skeleton, like on the Rock, you know,
like with the water, just
pounding on it, you know,
it's like the clothes all
messed up and he said he,
he moved his foot if wiggled his
foot and his whole body slipped out.
And so I said,
when I see my youngest daughter,
I'm going to wiggle my foot because I
keep pushing and prodding and cheese just
coming, you know, she's a hydraulic,
like it's not stopping, it's not UNCC.
Like she's younger than me.
She has more energy.
She's faster. I mean, you know, and so
I go, I'm just going to wiggle my foot,
like literally to the point where
even if I need the physical cue,
like if she's standing there doing some
of her weird bullshit, I'll just be like,
move my foot just to give them a trigger.
Like I've got a trigger myself,
I'm a parent, I'm like against the
ropes like everybody else. And so,
and I have a partner who supports me and
sometimes he looks at me like not, not,
not that strong of a game Gab.
And so,
so you know, we'll, we'll, we'll
get into it and I, and I'll,
and I'll go to pick her up. And
my whole thing is when, when I,
I talked to my kids in the morning,
like first thing I always say, hey,
good morning. Like I try really hard to
be the adult and to be the parent, right?
Like that's what I'm really want to do.
Like,
I really want to show up as
the adult and I'm flawed be it.
I still be like, you know what, I at
least she's acting like an adult that,
that woman over there, you
know, get me water. And so, uh,
she'll get in the car and I'll be like,
hi honey. How was your day at school?
You know, I try even though look, the
fake nice tone and everything. Yeah,
I don't really, you know, listen,
I spent almost seven hours there.
I really don't want to talk about school.
It's like a colossal waste of time.
How old is she? 11. She's like,
and then she says to me yesterday,
I'm not exaggerating. She goes,
you know, and if you listen,
no one fence. I'm sorry,
my mother trying to be rude.
I just, I, if you can't tell,
I don't like to talk that much.
It seems like a waste of time talking
as always to us. What she says,
she's very self contained and I'm
thinking through that, but okay.
So then I'm like, all right, well another
strategy. So I go, oh, that's cool.
I can be self contained. Like, I'm
cool, I don't need to beg. Oh Sweetie,
I don't care. No problem. I just click
over a little bit into my mail like, okay,
if I can drive this car and maybe I'm
going to drive a little faster and like
let's go and within three minutes somehow
all the things I said I wasn't going
to get lured into nothing.
I'm going to wiggle my foot,
all of this like philosophical stuff.
I've been reading books,
she gets me
and she's like 95 pounds and she gets me.
She's my only kid that gets me like
this and it's literally like if you went
into a restaurant and you said,
okay, I'm not going to order it.
A little design yet and the hamburger
and the double fries with the chili sauce
and you walk in and you go,
I'll take a little design.
You have the hamburger and the,
it's like the one thing I said I wasn't
going to do and she gets me every time.
So that's something I'm always
really trying to figure out.
And also like a survey back away
from I, this lady, actually,
you should have her on your show. Have
you ever heard of Byron Katie? No.
You got to get her, Jamie, you got to get
her. She's, she taught me a lot of stuff,
but it's basically like full and men
do this better generally and yes,
there are women that do it as well as men.
I'm not getting into all that,
but it's like surrendering like
maybe my kids gonna grow up
and they're going to be completely
different than what I thought or what they
would be or my expectations.
Um,
and that's actually probably
closer to the real, the real thing.
So I can be that, you know, going
through sports, I was like, man,
volleyball is way easier than
this. It is. It's just very,
it's cause it's straight forward.
Take the ball, hit the line,
take the ball and hit the other line. Oh,
okay. No, that was, did you complete that?
No, I didn't hit the line.
Okay. You hit the line.
Is your 11 year old involved in
sports? Oh yeah, the worst sport ever.
What's four horses?
It's like beauty pageants on big animals
were parents don't think it's cute to
take six year olds and think, oh
it's so sweet. We'll get them,
we'll go ride horses.
Cause then they fall in love with horses
and then they want better horses and
then they want and pretty horse pants
and then the boots and his the deep it'll
kill you. She, I have to say to her,
I'm sorry you not born to billionaires.
I'm really so sorry for you.
It's pretty heavy.
My middle daughter is into tennis and
she's pursuing tennis and I'm trying to
figure out how to manipulate my
young one out of away from horses.
And she'll say to me,
I know you think it's a phase and
it's not going to make it a not phase.
And she's,
and that's why I'm like no,
do whatever you want but you have to use
your own body at least a couple of days
a week. I go, cause you're using the
body of the horse. And by the way,
doesn't it frustrate you? I even tried
this. I can't believe I'm admitting this.
I mean I thought you guys
loved the animals. You know,
like you really loved horses and what
you're doing to them is not good for the
horses. They land on the same foot and
she's like, they jumped in nature. I go,
they don't, not with a hundred pounds
on their back. They don't, and not,
they don't land on the same leg. I've
tried that. I can't do that anymore.
That's not fair. And
then, um, I oh I totally,
and then the other thing I've tried is,
um,
doesn't irritate you if you are on a
horse and you were more talented as an
athlete or you had trained harder but
your horse was in as good so you couldn't
win.
And she just looks at me like I'm going
to ride this out. She doesn't care.
It's nothing impacts her.
Cause that's what frustrates me.
Imagine if it was like I had a better
guy than you so I could kick your ass.
And you know, Jujitsu cause Mikey
was more expensive. You'd be like,
wait a second,
I trained twice as hard as you.
I've been doing it longer and maybe
I'm just better than you. Nope.
Mikey's more expensive.
So if you have a shitty horse,
there's nothing you can do about it. And
the judges know, they know. They know.
So yeah, I would never get into
that. And I don't come from that.
I barely come from like if
I didn't hit a white ball,
I wasn't going even going to the
university, nevermind. Like you know,
this whole horse world
thing. God, I found myself,
I went to a show once and I was like
saying good morning to all the groomsmen.
Like good morning sir. Good afternoon and
like giving stink guide all the ladies,
you know, I was like, yeah, this is
an upside down here. Different thing.
Yeah. I just, I I really, this is one
of my, I lose sleep over this show.
Really? Yeah, I do. I do.
[inaudible] [inaudible] it's a lot
of money and that's not the part,
I mean I lose sleep over that too cause
I'm like, Larry's going to kill me. But,
um, because then the flip side of it
is I got a kid who's into something.
She'll go to the barn if she, if
you let her seven, eight hours,
she'll work with the horses, lunge him,
do all this stuff. So then you're like,
okay,
well she's into something.
This is not a kid who will sit around
and not do anything. But I just,
I guess for me it's the, you know, it's,
it's the, it's the money sport, you
know, take that weird bubble thing,
you know, so that, that part
was like, I was like, Oh God,
how did we get here? Yeah.
Yeah. That's what my friend is
dealing with, with his daughter.
How old is his daughter? She's
10. Oh, is he in deep already did,
is he Lisa Horace? Yeah. Got a horse.
They ha they bought a horse. Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I didn't know
you could lose the horse brokers.
There's a whole thing of size.
It's a shyster Mary hold trip.
It's super expensive to Lisa horse too,
right?
I think it's like 40 grand a month
or something crazy. That's like,
well then you've got a really fancy horse,
but it's expensive and made that
number up. Yeah, you did. And then
that's like bill gates daughter's
home. But then it's like, I dunno,
for me that's it. But again, as a parent
I have, these are one more of my lessons.
Like I'm not her and she's
not me. And I have, uh, I,
as much as I used to think I was
so in charge of so many things.
Yeah.
You know,
I think being in a long relationship,
I've been with Laird almost 24 years.
It's like you start to learn like,
oh, okay, I'm, I'm not, I can impact you.
I can influence you. I can
support you. I can love you. Um,
I could try to inspire
you, but, uh, not here to,
it's like even as a parent,
like I am not here to control anyone.
And that's a hard thing. Cause when
you get a little baby, you control,
you're in charge.
That's what you needed to be.
And then all of a sudden it's like, oh
yeah, no. And that shift is they don't,
I wish people need to talk
more about like the shift of,
cause we're not objective
and, uh, you know,
the tools that you need.
You got to keep adding tools and it's,
it's very humbling.
Do you find it easier to
do on [inaudible] or at,
in California? Cause any different?
Well it depends, right? So if I have a,
my middle daughter who's
a teenager not on Kohai,
she looks 18 or 19 and uh, you
know, there's not a lot to do.
And uh, so that's tricky. They're here.
Like she, she basically lives
at a tennis house and she goes,
she's homeschooled and she does
five to seven hours of tennis.
Her choice as of in the
last couple of months.
So it's easier cause there's just
more productive things to do. Um,
what I like is when they're little
[inaudible] great because it's so simple.
Life is simple.
So what kids are thinking about is like
playing and being in nature and like
developing also a toughness to them that
maybe like city kids have it different
cause like they're barefoot and they're
like climbing trees and they're throwing
rocks at each other and it's just
like a little more rough and tumble.
So when they're little
[inaudible] he certainly easier.
And then as they get older, that's
what we're, where we're sort of at now.
It's like you got to adapt and put
these kids, give them a launching pad,
if you will, because
a, the problem is like,
and I went through
growing up in an island,
it's like you don't know all that's
out there to dream to do and it's,
even if it's, you know,
everything in life,
it's so true about like
being like the alchemists.
Like I even see it with layered,
it's like he went out into the world,
he's done all this stuff and there are
certain things we're doing in projects
right back on Nicole [inaudible] and,
and so there's always going to
be that element probably of um,
I went and I did all these things.
I express myself all these ways.
And then there's some basic parts about
where I exactly started that are still
really important to me. But I think
it's important for kids to see,
like it doesn't matter where
you're from or how you grew up.
Like certainly Laird and I both
the same way. It's like you,
you really could try to do anything and,
and pursued that if it's in you,
if it's genuinely in you and calling you.
And I want that for my kids and
I don't care what that is. Um,
but just that they have something that
they get up each day and they're like, Yo,
I'm turned on.
Yeah. That really is what people need to
really need. Something they love doing.
That's it.
And I think that's when I was talking
about success is sometimes we have all
this,
you know,
kind of bells and whistles and
attention around getting attention.
And I think people don't realize
that getting attention. I mean,
you know this for yourself.
It's like, yeah, it's great,
but what is it like what does it really?
And when you close the doors and you're
hanging with your people that are,
you're close to,
it's like,
you know what's making you excited
for real and who loves you for real?
And that way of like,
it's great if people appreciate your work.
That always feels good. But if you're
doing it for your real reasons,
then I already think
that is a real success.
Um,
and we spent a lot of time working,
so why not have something
that we're fired up on?
And that's the thing because it's like,
you know,
you spent a long time of your life
working. What do you want to do?
Yeah.
That and then guiding a child into that
direction of trying to set them up in a
way that they view their life as kind of
a project and the most enjoyment you're
going to get as find a thing that excites
you to find the thing that you really
get inspired by some the
whatever the fuck it is,
it's going to be different
for you than it is for me.
They've got to find out what that
thing is, but it's all the same thing.
Once you find out what the thing is and
that that thing genuinely gels with your
personality and your likes
and your passion, just run
with it. You can do it. Yeah,
you can run with it and it
changes too. I think that's the other
thing is also we get defined like, okay,
you were doing this one job and then
it's like, okay, but that job is over.
Like it's like being an athlete
or an, you know, a Pr, you know,
competing competitive athlete on an
organized platform that has it a day and a
time.
And then when that's over,
do you want to look back and keep talking
about that or do you want to look and
see who you are now and who you'd like
to be? And I think that that's always a,
you know, kind of an important thing to
teach people, especially people that have,
well I'm, I'm a comedian, I
was a professional athlete.
It's like, okay, that's cool.
I had some guy coming to
me once and say, Hey, I'm,
I was at the golf course and I was,
one of my kids were hitting golf
balls and he goes, where are you?
That volleyball player Gabby? And I was
like, oh well no, I'm, I'm still Gabby.
But one of the things I've
done is play volleyball.
And I think that that actually, if we
can get to that, that's even better.
It's like who am I?
And then off of this non,
you know,
as far as like whether you're older or
younger or in one part of your career or
not, it's like you still can
always be the essence of yourself.
And then it's like, oh, and now,
right now I'm doing this and that.
And I was, you know, but I'm not,
I'm not for all time. Just, you know,
a volleyball player fighters
have a huge problem with that.
They identify as being fighters so much
that once they retire, they almost,
almost all of them,
except for a small percentage,
almost all of them come back because
they just, they miss it so much.
They miss the excitement and the thrill
and they don't know who they are.
Without that pursuit,
the pursuit is the next fight.
The F pursued his training
camp getting ready.
And when they don't have
that for a long time,
it just starts really chipping away
at them. Well, and I think too,
the amount of focus it takes to be really
good at that kind of stuff or to run a
company or anything.
It makes sense why it's so hard to try
to diversify while you're doing that.
It is really hard.
But I think it's important to quietly
keep that voice inside your head going,
yeah, but who are you, um,
beyond that expression of
yourself? Who are you, what do you,
how do you feel about things?
Um,
and also the opportunity like
to kind of grow up, you know,
there's so many opportunities, like
30, 40, 50 like to try to try to,
and I don't mean grow up in the notion
of like you're so responsible now.
I mean like grow up in a
way that like maybe you,
you change your ideas and the way you
do things. And you know, I was talking,
I was telling Larry,
I was in this situation this week where I,
something had gone down.
I didn't like the way it had gone down.
It wasn't to do with him. And
I was like, you know what, I'm,
I'm not going to attach to
this. Like I, I know better.
So now I'm just going to notice that
it kind of bugs me and I'm not going to
attach all the way to that feeling
and to that experience. And I,
and for me that's more what I mean about
growing up, not like being, you know,
grown up.
Because I actually think that the more
grown up we are also means we could
probably be more childlike too for sure.
Both.
So it isn't about like be responsible,
it's just a different freedom.
So I mean I,
I would think in the end that that would
be a more interesting quest then I was
a champion. Anything, I don't know,
and it's not sexy and it's internal,
but I dunno,
it's can be I think pretty rich.
But I think ultimately for a person
who's experienced athletic highs, uh,
the highs of
accomplishments but also
understands real personal struggle,
that's when like a person like you, you've
experienced so many different things,
you can you and understand what's
actually beneficial towards you. Right.
And it's pretty simple. I hate to,
that's kind of the heavy part. It's like,
it's like being married to Laird Laird
is once it got to bed at eight 30 and
Laird wants to get up early and
he keeps it pretty simple. And I,
it's an interesting thing
because within it there's, um,
yeah,
he seems pretty good.
I mean,
as long as there's sometimes
waves because that guy is like,
that seems like a,
that's pretty straight forward.
Well that's it, right? Like how do
I, how do I get the highest ideas,
the biggest ideas,
you know,
whether it's like I'm
dealing with ego or whatever,
get the biggest ideas and then get
everything else pretty stripped down.
Pretty simple. Yeah.
Because otherwise it just,
I feel like you're running around and I'm,
I like,
I love the days I'm running around
and I'm like, what am I reacting to?
Like what the fuck? Like what do, what is
going on? Like I'm like a crazy person.
Right. And then it's like, okay, you
know, you got to back it up and it,
and listen with kids, it's hard because
you're only as good as like your,
whatever your kids are going through. I
mean, and then there's elements of it,
like they're going through things and you
go, it's probably pretty natural. Yep.
Even if it's super hard, it's
like, and that's okay too.
And you don't want that for
them. But I think, you know,
that's something I've really
learned is like I had to, God,
it's a bummer that you have to go
through that and it's hard to watch and I
don't want you to, and that's
okay too because that's part of,
it's really cool though to see them come
out in the other end and then talk to
you about it. Oh, it's not bothering me
so much more. Um, yeah, I get it. Yeah,
I was just upset,
but I'm all right.
You know, and it was really cool.
Uh, Dang I learned, cause I, I am,
you know, listen, I'm
pretty Siri, not Siri.
I'd say I'm a pretty serious person.
Like Laird is sort of the lighter
person of the two of us. And I,
someone sort of gave me some information
about like not resisting with my kids.
Like my oldest was going
through something and I said,
I just need to tell you how I feel about
this, but I didn't make it a big deal.
I just sort of dropped it off
and said, hey, this I'm feeling.
And she said to me very
clearly when she was like 22,
uh, I, this just feels like
something I have to do.
And I remember thinking, I felt like that
and nobody understood what I was doing.
And I understood I had to,
something I had to do for my
reasons and I was right for myself.
And what I did is I just
went, okay, I get it.
And where I wanted her to end up happen
so much quicker because I didn't put up
the resistance. And that's
the other thing. I mean,
how long does it take me to learn
that one? It's like, you know,
not having to try to resist or navigate
every single situation in disco.
Okay. And then you get through it so much
faster and they get through it. No, no,
you're Lord Subaru in nutrition layered
has is you guys have this company
[inaudible] Laird superfood. Yeah.
De Force has stuff when your kids,
are you kidding? My kids, if they
want to eat pasta and whatever,
they can eat whenever they want.
Yeah,
because I cooked dinner so we know
what dinner looks like. My kids,
I always say just now, what's the
difference between food and fun? Be Clear.
Bagel is a lot of fun.
It's not food because I just want to send
them into the world equipped with the
information on how they can
take care of themselves.
Because if you make anything a thing,
don't have that.
When they go to their friend's house,
they'll have a bag of chips, the clicker,
and there'll be like, I love it
here. So, um, I am like, yeah,
whatever you want.
And my kids eat pretty healthy.
That's awesome that
they listened that way.
They don't listen well that they've
figured it out, that they eat healthy.
Smart. We'll also, okay, so my middle
for a minute, like never met a carve.
She didn't like right. And it was
like, it was bad for a minute.
She was like 12, 13,
whatever. And then, uh, she,
and she knows the difference and she
was also using food to sack, you know,
kind of assuage some
feelings and other stuff too.
That's interesting thing. But then
she's come around, but it's not,
let's not pretend that my kids listen.
They don't, their costs a little,
no they don't. No, they
don't. Your example,
that's more they're watching but they
don't listen. You think in a way Laird,
I could be sort of maybe imposing parents
in some way and I'm telling you they
are not. They don't, it doesn't,
they? They look at us like,
what do you got? It's like,
come on, it's your move.
So I've just learned
like it's your choice.
Like this is what I'm serving for dinner.
I don't have pop in the house obviously,
but if like we want someplace,
you know, I showed him a
picture when they were little.
I remember the guy who did like
eat this, not that Dave, uh,
with the Z for men's
health, the editor. Anyway,
it was like seven or eight chocolate chip
cookies and a sun kissed soda opposite
each other. And I'm like, do you want
to cookies or do you want that soda?
And they got it. It's like, oh okay. Cause
it showed how much sugar was in both.
So it's just that kind of stuff.
But they don't,
it's not like we live so healthy
and they listen. You know,
I mean, Ben Greenfield, right? He
lives in like the forest and they,
that's different.
It's a different level of control.
I don't have that kind of control.
Yeah.
Ben's got a weird thing going
on out there. His kids listen,
they must, they're out in the forest.
You have to, that's what I mean.
I'm saying I don't have that
level of containment that, uh,
that he has to do with predators,
like living predators.
You really let your kids just go
loose and your backyard. No, I know.
Keep an eye on them.
It's easier than Coca Cola and
cheeto zone a different kind of way.
I'm just saying like predators, very
straight forward. Like it's a predator.
Don't go out there. It's like, well, you
know, this food, it's in a bag. It's got,
you know, it's not that good for
you. Your cell functions like, okay,
what am my friends do it?
It's like, you know, Predator.
So I just think, I don't
know. I just think, uh,
I think I've surrendered to the idea of
them listening and I've just tried to
show them the best example and they are
intelligent people that I have faith and
will arrive at their own conclusion.
And by the way,
you know, they make, make other
choices. I don't think so though.
How many kids leave Kohai
like when they grow up?
Not many, I don't think. I think it's,
it's tough because it is so beautiful
and magical and on some level intuitively
it makes so much sense there. You know
what I mean? Like it makes a lot of sense,
right? Like the foods growing,
there's certain things that you,
and you go into the real
world and you're like, Whoa,
do they have good supermarkets
there? Yeah. Just everything.
Costs of a box of cereal is
like $9. Whoa. No, for real.
So it's hard,
but some kids leave.
I would think that that would
be a difficult transition
between going from quiet,
like moving to Chicago or
something like that. It can be,
especially if it's like December,
but I think you'd be surprised. Yeah.
Let me tell you, the cold is shocking
when you come from an island.
Like Larry goes snowboarding,
I'm like Alaska and stuff like that
cause he loves all that. Right.
But I grew up in Saint Thomas
and I'm just like, you know,
five days in the cold I'm like, this is
so beautiful. And then I'm like, I'm good.
You know. But I think you
know, listen island people,
they either like Jones for the big city
or the number one tourist destination
for Hawaiians. Do you know
what it is? What Vegas?
Cause it's not really well cause it's
opposite, right? It's like, it's like uh,
everything's artificial age and then you
have a lot of like Filipino, Japanese,
Chinese, Hawaiians, so like
fine gambling, things like that.
Oh yeah.
It's a number one like Hawaiian Airlines.
That's their number one destination
for locals. They go to Vegas. Wow.
I mean cause it's the
antithesis, right? Yeah.
I guess you see the Strip and
all the neon, the craziness.
Totally giant flashing.
Yes. And that a drop of water
or not anything natural.
Like you're not really
supposed to be there. You know,
like there's no garden of Eden.
That makes sense. Oh totally.
So either either they
adapt, they go like, Hey,
I want to be a designer and live
in New York. Or um, you know,
that's gotta be the ultimate one 80
culture shock. They have that though.
For sure. Yeah, for sure.
They have that. I think I,
I'm with Laird though about living there.
Whenever I go there I'm like,
what in the fuck is this? I love
it. I love New York for like a week.
Well you can get stuff done in
New York and to a real New Yorker.
There's no other place like
New York. Right? Like I can
get whatever food I want.
Exactly how I want it.
There's that and I can get stuff done.
And you're also breathing in
dust all day. Yeah, it's tough.
And I don't think we're supposed to be
living on stacked on top of each other.
That's the thing. And there's always
like, yeah, something goes wrong.
This is the worst place you ever want
to be. Like garbage, water, toilets.
He's like, cause he's always thinking
about like if they turn the power off,
what's going to happen? Yeah. So
that's how he kind of how he lives.
I mean we had a uh,
a hundred year rain and [inaudible]
April five feet in a day.
Yeah. It was pretty radical. So, and
then, then we went through the fires.
So it's just like I think
fires and it rains that month.
Well know in map then we were here in
Malibu and so we had that like within six
months after. So I think he's always,
and I think, you know, listen,
when people do things in nature,
like rock climbers are big
wave surfers or whatever,
they're more in tune with the fact
that like stuff does go wrong.
And so they're not assuming that it's
always going to be as it always is.
So big storms out there where,
and quiet like hurricanes,
they haven't had really a
significant one since in Niki,
which I believe was in [inaudible]
92 which was really bad.
I think it was the lar,
the fastest wind speed
to hit land ever far.
Where you guys as the crow
flies from like the big island.
He's got [inaudible],
he's got a thing for the big island.
What's happened to you on the Big Island?
I love it there.
Did you have like an experience or no.
Do you go on a spiritual
journey or anything? I like
it there because it's, uh,
it's, it's, it's like a good
medium. Like, Yup. I get it.
Not quite as populated as Maui.
It's not as metropolitan. No,
but it's still pretty big.
Whereas Lanai is probably my favorite.
Really interesting. It's so quiet
and yeah, I hunt for like a day.
Oh, there we go. And it makes sense.
It's also a overpopulated,
so it's like the most,
it's like the best ethical
argument for hunting. Yeah.
Currently available in the
United States of America,
if you want to call Hawaii
the United States of America.
I know if you ask a Hawaiian like,
oh, you're American. They're like,
you know Hawaiian? Yeah, they're
Hawaiian. I'm quiet is the most north.
So it's the other end of the chain.
So how far away would it be?
So if you were going to fly
in an airplane, it's an hour,
45 or 45 minutes because of takeoff
and landing. If it was like straight,
like we whip, we go on a plane,
it's probably 28 minutes.
So how many miles is that?
Cause you're going 500 miles an hour.
It's a couple hundred miles.
Yeah, it is. Wow. Yeah, no, yeah,
yeah. No, I mean it's an amazing new
island forming right now, but yeah,
I like your fascination with Hawaii or
love it out there. I really do. Yeah,
it's great. Steven [inaudible] tried
to talk me into moving them out.
[inaudible] he loves it out there.
Really loves it.
Loves.
Yeah,
he gets out.
Yeah.
I mean he flies around,
does this Aerosmith shows and does
that television show and all that jazz,
but he loves Maui.
Yeah. You don't love it
too much. I do love Maui.
I guess I lived there also when it
was like a little less populated,
so it's like anything when you watch it,
you just to kind of go, whoa. But it's a,
it's a great blend for me.
It has still nothing compared to this.
Like I was just a, I mean it's
like this is, that's all right.
Well we're here is crazy. Ellis, what
do we have? Like 35 million people here?
Something preposterous.
It didn't even know really.
They're just guessed what he like the
ninth largest economy in the world. Yeah.
I told her when we had this whole
thing with all the, the Mexican,
you know the Mexican,
you know,
whatever non illegal whatever.
I said,
I have a friend of mine who, he's from
here but he's from Mexico and I said,
you should band together.
You have the ninth largest economy in
the world and get together and have
demands because you're helping run the
ninth largest economy in the world. Well,
that's what's hilarious about people
that want the immigrants to go back to
Mexico, listens to bid.
This thing would fall apart.
He told them when you talked to go
mobilize, let's go, and he was like,
what's crazy about it? It's like
they're already a part of the system.
Like why don't they get the benefits?
I said,
I think that he was laughing because when
I went to see him, I go, how's it going?
He goes, well, hopefully I'm here
tomorrow, joking, you know, and I go,
you guys have like
you're making it happen.
Get people to organize like that. They're
so worried about being shipped out now.
Ice,
you know,
I had a friend of mine who was a
veteran and he's an older gentleman,
he's in his fifties he got
up, pulled over at ice. Oh,
come on at the home depot.
They asked him where he's born and he say,
hey asshole, you're not supposed
to ask questions like that,
like you don't have a warrant to do.
And he started grilling the guys and he
pulled out his military id. He's like,
what the fuck are you guys
doing here? What do you think
you're doing? Yeah, yeah,
I'm American. I was born in America.
He goes, I'm an American citizen.
I'm also a veteran. And then he started,
he goes like, you guys, this is illegal.
And that's supposed to talk to people
this. But they could do that to people
that don't know and are scared. Right?
I mean,
yeah, but you, if you're just an
American citizen at fucking Home Depot,
you're not supposed to get harassed by
some guy who thinks you might be Mexican
because you're brown and brown
skin. Yeah, it's fucking crazy.
But it's just also like,
is this really where our problems are?
What about these using these resources
in a positive way because a lot of shit
that needs to get done,
but that's ever, I
mean, that's everywhere.
Thinking about how much time gets spent
on not doing anything and going the
other direction.
I don't know.
Well the, isn't that less of a problem
though when you have a small community,
like why that's gotta be looking at
a huge alleviation of frustration.
This is just the giant masses of
people and the stupid jobs everywhere.
It's like you got guys kind of kind of
boiled down to a much more natural state
one, it's all very accountable,
right? Like if I say something too,
I don't get to walk away from that.
Right. On a fucking little island,
I'm going to see a 50 more times that day.
And so I got to own it if I, you know,
and that,
that was all Laird's biggest adjustment
is because everything he does and says
he is owns it.
And so he,
when he first came here and like if even
driving, if someone flicked him off,
like you just don't do that in
Hawaii, could you, I know your truck.
Like I know you, I know your sister.
Like I'm coming to your house, you know,
like what are you talking about?
Right.
And I've been with him where he has pulled
people over and said, listen, like you,
you can't go and just like
drop off aggressive gestures.
Uh, you just don't know who,
like, what's up with people.
Like you've got to be accountable like
this, like, you know, and I'm like, okay,
well you cannot stop every vehicle and
jump out and be like, hey, you know, but
no, he's done it here. No,
you don't have to do it there cause
there and here it's dangerous. Yeah,
I guess 10 B it can be, it's
true. It can be, and he's,
but again, he's, he's older and wiser.
I'm talking about like maybe when we
first were together in his early thirties
crazy Laird, but he still has a look at
his eye where it's like, I don't know.
Yeah, I get it. Like, well,
if you're really used to that environment
to where everybody is accountable and
then you see these just
assholes. Yeah. Well that's it.
And also if you really said, okay,
let's go outside, they'd be like,
I'm going to get a lawyer. I think
for him, that's the weird twisty part.
It's like in Hawaii, if they say it, it's
like, okay, let's go. At least it's like,
okay, I'm going to stand
up to own the words I say,
and everything here it's like if you
go okay, and they go, no, you know,
I'm going to call somebody.
It's like, he's like, okay,
well, which is it? You know?
Like I always tell my kid that was my
one daughter does that. She'll be like,
really aggressive and then you, if
you call her on it, she gets like,
she's the victim. I go, no, no, you
have to pick like which one are you?
Are you like aggressive or are you
the victim? But I don't know. I,
I think it's interesting, he, he will
call people out every time though.
If they are acting weird, he'll just say
like, what's up? Or How's your day? 10?
And I'm like,
oh people are not accustomed to,
because in Hawaii they were just very
respectful that way. And welding,
there's accountability.
And I think
there's also a lot of fighters come out
of Hawaii. Well cause it's a fighting,
it's a warrior culture.
So you know like uncle
slapped boys' heads and like,
and it's also now because of the Brazilian
influence coming in, now you've got,
you know, Jujitsu and, and
also I think about this,
they're pretty strong,
right? And, and so contact,
they don't mind little contact,
like they even joke about like Polynesian
rugby players. Like it's like, oh fun.
Like Oh, you know, like
we're leveling each other.
So you're also talking about people who
maybe they don't mind a little little
contact, you know, like playful
because they are also playful.
So it's also like this weird
thing of like, I'm not,
I don't take myself so serious. So there's
like a playfulness but also like, oh,
we're gonna do you notice a big difference
between like female athletes and male
athletes? Like, okay.
Cause fighting is a pretty,
I don't want to say exaggerated,
but it's an interesting thing where,
you know, you have men and women kind of
differently, but doing the same thing,
if you will. Yeah. Um, do you notice
a difference in their mentality?
Um,
well they vary so much individually.
That's what's interesting.
It's like you'll find even male fighters
are like super laid back and then you
find other ones that are really
intense and super emotional and uh,
it's really hard to tell.
Like there's a,
there's Gunnar Nelson is a
guy from Iceland, you know,
is, I know who he is. Yeah.
Fantastic. Jujitsu guy. You cannot
get that guy to change as expression.
It doesn't change. You could punch him,
kick him in the balls. He stay stoic.
It's a weird, he's a weird guy.
Yeah. He's very on one side of it.
And then there's like,
I like Conor Mcgregor who's also his
training partner who's on a completely
different side of it.
He's screaming and yelling and talking
shit to everybody and you know, that's,
that's part of his flair. Right. You
know, they vary so widely and it's,
that's true with girls too.
Some girls are brash and outrageous and
they get another girl's faces and put
their knuckles on their nose and when
they're at the stare down and other girls
bow on the hug and they
take selfies together,
it's like everyone has their own
sort of approach to it. Yeah.
It's very interesting.
It is interesting. I'm always, I'm,
I'm in fighting and intrigues me and
that I think it's interesting that you're
trying to be offensive and defensive
at the same time dealing with fear,
like all these things happening
simultaneously. And I then take it,
I look at it one step further
with a female because,
okay.
I don't know. I, I, I'm
interested to know how if,
if a female can fight from a
non non anonymous [inaudible]
place but without her
emotion,
like just like okay I'm in my mail,
I'm in my athlete and um,
I'm not going to be like,
oh she didn't just kick me in the
ear, you know, and like freak out.
You know what I mean? Like cause I think
about myself and I'd be like, you know,
like I've only been in one
fight my whole life and,
and the girl hit me in the face and
when I saw my blood I was like, oh no,
she did not just hit me in the
face, you know, and then went crazy.
But if these girls could be like, cause
they're so well trained as an athlete,
how that can supersede or
override actually like this
in the feminine impulse of
like a, you know, reaction, a reaction.
Masculine impulse to though
I think it's a human impulse.
If a guy punches you in the face,
you get furious.
It's so hard for people to
not get emotional when they
get hit because you want
to get it back.
That's a good point.
It's a very bad way to react in a fight
to fight with emotions because you
expose yourself, right? You leave
yourself open for counters, you just, you,
you miss your rhythm. You not as
deceptive and your, your emotions,
you're too and your pattern
and so many times you,
you get hit a lot more and it's a,
it's a big problem with fighters. That
emotion, that's a very big problem.
And the wanting to break people,
like letting them hit you so that
you could show them that they,
they can hurt you. I think
it's a masculine thing to
stupid. It's a very stupid,
take it on the face on purpose and then
just like, come on, come on, come on,
hit me.
Yeah.
Then that's a terrible emotion though
cause you can get completely knocked
unconscious doing that
happens all the time.
It's just the smart thing to do is to
fight with correct technique and with a
correct strategy,
meaning you have an understanding
of how to execute best.
It's not to just wait in and let
bombs fly. It's, you have to,
you have to be very precise in your
tactics. You've got to be very smart.
I think it's interesting though, um,
those sports where there is that,
I mean, listen, versions of
it is football. You know,
living with layered, obviously,
you know,
he always says he appreciates mother
nature because it's like you make good
decisions. You're rewarded, you make
bad decisions, you, you pay a price.
But I think it is very interesting when
you have two humans strategically trying
to deconstruct one another. Um, the chest,
the physical chest that goes on as like
looking at it from another athlete's
point of view.
Um,
I think it's a unique person that wants
to put themselves in that situation.
You know, it's like, I understand
almost like, uh, you know,
a surfer and a wave and a rock
climber and a mountain. I get that.
Like I'm going to be a part of that.
Um,
but I find it really
interesting and even sort of,
I'm even more curious about
women, like who say like, yeah,
this is going to be my sport
wildly. Uh, like there's Holly Holm.
She just seems like awfully sweet.
She seemed like she'd bring you cupcakes
or murder you kick your fucking ice
pack. I mean, listen, I saw
that kick, but then it's like,
I'm so sorry I made you these after, you
know, chocolate chip cookies. It's like,
okay, I'll get it. You know,
when I come back from the
hospital, I don't know. It's,
it is interesting when you see girls
like that. Well, they're all different.
I always want to know,
did they have brothers,
like where they rabble rousing and
that their whole time and it wasn't,
and they learned to play in,
it wasn't personal, you know,
and like a little contact
was okay. Maybe. I mean,
I'm Ronda Rousey his case. It
was also, it was very much right.
Her mom was a world judo champion.
Her mom was a pieced.
She's had an interesting path,
I think.
Right? Yeah. Yeah. I'm wonder how
much she loves the WWE. I wonder,
I always wonder when a person is like an
elite athlete at the highest level one,
a real one.
If they,
they still enjoy doing that because
I think she enjoyed it though.
I think she was a fan of it.
Yeah,
for sure. Yeah. I think she actually
enjoyed pro wrestling, you know,
and she doing athletic things even though
it's obviously flying off of an into
and around. I mean it's
athletic, but it's scripted. Yes,
it's not competition.
But then again,
you could only get knocked
unconscious so many times.
You can only get fucked up so
many times and she got fucked up.
Two fights in a row really bad.
The Holly Holm Kao Ruthless.
That was brutal.
And then Amanda Nunez just punched her
face and for 48 seconds it was horrific.
That was hard to watch.
I like to watch, I mean,
I don't like to watch a really big
guys punch each other and women,
I don't know why.
Like when guys are a little smaller,
it's easier to watch as long as they're
not kicking themselves in the head.
I'm just saying. So the big scary ones
like heavyweights dropping bombs on, yeah,
you just go, oh my God, that just that
guy I took eight years off that guys,
you know, it was definitely
different. Notice it like a,
there's certain heavyweights and they hit
guys and they get knocked unconscious,
whether it's Frances and gone who or
steep Vimeo church or these big guys and
they slammed, someone's like, oh my God.
That's what I mean. Like I watch that.
I don't actually, I mean violence. I know
it's sport. For me it's, oh, it's violent.
It is.
Yeah.
It is a very dangerous path that you
have to know when to get off and more,
I dunno if I would say more so than other
combat sports, but yeah, it makes sense.
All of them, all of them have a path.
But I think very specifically MMA has,
you have to be really careful because
the consequences are so great.
There's not enough padding and
those gloves are tiny little things.
You could also get kicked.
He could get kneed in the face,
elbowed in the face and once you've
realized the Chin starts going and your
reflex is start going and you're,
you're slowing down.
Like you got to get out and out,
got to get out.
And sometimes they don't get the proper
advice and sometimes they don't know
what else to do. They don't have anywhere
else to go. And that goes back to, yeah,
I was talking,
I talked to Larry about that cause we
have tons of friends in organized sports
stuff.
Like you have to be drafted or coach,
the team has to pick you up or you know,
whatever.
And I say to him like how fortunate
are you that you're in a sport
like other athletes, like a snowboarder
or whatever that you can go,
you can go out. Yeah. You want
to ride, you can go right.
Nobody's dictating to you.
And if you're really smart and you're
managing yourself and your health and your
wellbeing and your melon and everything
else, you could write a really long time.
Yeah. That's a big difference between
that and a competitive fighter.
55 years of age, you aren't doing shit
getting hit over and over. No chance.
I mean you could still train in
certain aspects, especially Jujitsu.
Lot of people deepen their
sixties seventies, 80s train. Uh,
you can definitely do that. But there's
a such a such a difference, you know,
layered can go out there and do what
he wants to do at the same level he was
able to do two decades ago.
It's,
it's exhausting actually to live with.
I swear to God
cause I feel like Laird is like I in
this way of like when you live with
somebody that's sort of, you know, it's
like, I mean you, you have a partner,
it's like in ways there a
reference to you in certain ways.
And so I, if I like living with him and
you're referencing him as an athlete,
you're just like, oh man, I gotta get,
I gotta get busy. I got to get training,
I got to get moving. You know, it's
just like, cause he's, he's nonstop,
that guy cause he has to, that's
a different type. You know, I,
a lot of times I'll train cause I'm like,
Hey,
I know how good I feel when I'm done and
it's important and I have other stuff I
need to do but I'm going to get it in.
And for a guy like that,
it's just like what it would be like if
I took an 80 pound dumbbell and saw at
the bottom of the pool for a minute
and then tried to do 15 you know,
it's just like he also
has a creative approach.
I'm more linear and it's like for
time and for this and he's like,
let's just go until we can't
anymore. It's like, okay,
when's that drill going to end?
You know what I mean?
Do you train with them? Only
in the pool. I'm telling you,
you got to come with a friend and
someone that you feel safe with.
And I'm going to be honest with you.
We have fighters and trainers
have the hardest time in the pool.
Really? Yes. And I'll tell you
why. A lot of them are built,
they have a lot of mass. Okay.
Like it. So number one right there.
Just the mass, like you're more
dense, you go to the bottom. Okay. Um,
the other side of it is they're used to
doing everything quickly and the water's
like, awesome that you want to do it
quick, this is how we're going to do it.
Right. And so it's a pretty cool
environment. Um, but we've had a lot of,
we've had fighters and
trainers and they're built for,
but once obviously once they get the
hang of it, but I think it's, um,
it's pretty special to the training
because you, when you're done, again,
it goes back to I am like a noodle,
you're exhausted and your
joints are not just hammered.
So this is called [inaudible].
It's like,
it's part of the whole thing
that you could follow. Yeah.
I mean the pool training though,
it's like you have to kind of do it with
somebody, someone else to show you. Yeah.
I mean we started, originally it was like
we were weight vests and Laird's like,
just go try it as long as you can. And
it's like, okay, I think I'm good now.
Like I, I cannot swim anymore,
you know, I can't tread anymore.
And then w it was actually
one of my daughters,
she might've been like
six or seven at the time,
maybe younger and she would swim to the
surface with a dumbbell and learns like,
Oh,
what if we made you had reps and you do
sequencing where you're on an exhale or
on an inhale or whatever. He'll
go from like, uh, you know,
I versa climber or a bike and have
your heart rate way up and then go,
okay,
now you're going to do the set.
So it's like there's all these ways to
adapt and it's pretty cool I think for
people who train. That's the whole thing
is how do you keep modifying and like,
do you get locked in like on your
training or do you keep going, okay,
I've heard you talk about like, Oh,
I've added Yoga and all these things.
Like that's the other thing is like
you get pretty good at something,
but now how do you keep kind of adding,
doing things that you're sort of unsure,
you're uncomfortable, you're not good at.
I think that that's always been
easier for layered than me.
I've always sort of going like, well no,
I'm good over here. Like I do this good.
It's like, okay, change it up, you
know? So I think that's been a,
I think that's a thing. So that's,
that has everything that has,
we do a lot of breathing,
heat and ice cause his other thing is
like active recovery. People go, oh I'm,
I'm half a day off. It's like, okay,
so what are you going to do to actively
recover? Not just take the day off.
So I think he's, you know, been really
into that. But so active recovery,
meaning you do some breathing or something
mellow so that you can participate in
helping the body actually recover,
not just sit around.
How much of would benefit is that?
And like doing something physical as
opposed to just sitting around doing
nothing?
I think it's,
I think it makes a huge difference
because I don't think it's about,
I have to tax my, my adrenals are
my nervous system or any of that.
I think it's okay. I'm going to
take a very, uh, you know, uh,
a Yin Yoga class.
So the poses are along,
it won't be like necessarily a high
flow class or I'm going to do multiple
series of heat and ice.
Like some days he'll go and just do three
rounds in the sauna and three rounds
of the ice or I'm going to do
35 or 45 minutes of breathing,
you know, recovery, breathing,
things like that to really oxygenate
the tissue and the cells and things like
that.
So I think it's just kind of looking
at what a day off looks like and making
that something that you participate in,
in,
in supporting the recovery, not just
I laid around now having said that,
there are days where after you're
done with that, yeah, great.
Lay around like go to sleep early,
eat extra more calories,
whatever you need to do.
But I think active recovery,
even riding a bike, you know,
flushing the system, the tissue,
things like that. I think, uh,
people think, uh, you know,
off means like nothing.
And I think doing something or for a
certain athletes like maybe get a massage
that day, that might be
the best thing, you know.
So I think for him it's filling it out.
Do you guys use any electronics look in
terms of apps or heart rate monitors or
anything along those lines? Not too,
too much. I used to use a fitbit, um,
layered uses a ox oximeter,
x oximeter oximeter to like if he does
a breathing to see if he can get as him
self up to altitude. So he'll use
that to measure and things like that.
But I think once you do something,
I'm really,
really long time.
You sort of go on my n the edge or Rni.
Um,
he'll use electronics more
for speed and distance.
He'll put it on his boards and be like,
okay,
we went x miles and the
peak speed was whatever,
50 miles an hour.
So he'll use it more for that to,
to measure distance on how
many miles he wrote day, um,
on the water,
but not necessarily micromanaging,
uh, electronically. All the
metrics. Now, having said that,
if you were an athlete where you know,
little seconds here and there made a
difference, maybe you would write, um,
or you know, checking your heart rate and
things like that, but not, not too often.
No. Yeah, I would think that like
things like heart rate variability,
finding out if you're
recovering correctly. Yeah.
Not your, your heart rate.
It varies in the morning,
right. Day to day. But yeah,
that makes a big difference
between if you're,
if you're doing something
like Michael Phelps
that was,
trying to think so,
or track athletes where it's all these
milliseconds I think for layer it's like
I feel good today and I'm going to
go, well, there's a lot more natural.
It's more natural thing, isn't it?
Like those days like you go, wow, I am,
I'm tired today and I'll just
kind of do the best I can. Yeah.
But I think I understand wanting to
measure things and also sort of saying,
I feel tired because there's
an interesting thing of
feeling tired physically,
but you're actually emotionally tired
because if you look at your metrics on
your physical,
you have a lot more to give.
And so it's Kinda then checking in and
saying, well, what's going on for me?
I'm usually more tired personally
than I am physically, you know,
like especially with your 11 year
old giving you shit. [inaudible] man,
she's awesome. She's so, but
that's what I'm saying, like
I can be wiped out. Right,
right,
right.
I could train for an hour and I could
hang out with birdie 13 minutes in the car
and she's the victor, like, you know,
her foot's on my hip and she's standing,
you know, in the post. Um,
and that has been my lesson.
That's one of my many lessons.
Ongoing lessons is like,
you can't, you cannot go
at everything head on. And,
uh, I've learned that certainly
being in a marriage, uh, I,
I developed a little bit of finesse and,
uh,
and as a parent just kind of going like,
I'm here to love you.
I'm here to support you and I'm also
going to recognize that, um, you know,
you're probably not going to always
do it hardly ever actually the way I,
I think you should or I want you to.
So what made you guys start,
um,
putting together the coffee and the super
foods supplements and all that? Yeah,
by accident. Really. Um, what
happened is, is layered used to,
he's been in as far as
long as I've known him.
He's had coffee come from all around.
He's of coffee freak.
And then what happened is Paul
Chek, I don't know, 16 years ago,
gave him d in His coffee and the two of
those animals would be like down in the
coffee.
Well getting all jacked up on caffeine
and I'd be standing in the gym waiting
for them being like, oh my God, like
hanging out with these too, you know,
for the next two hours ramped up on,
on a fat and coffee,
which is basically the Dave Asprey concept
of like Yak butter tea and you know,
fat and things like that.
So the bulletproof concept.
So Larry used to start to mess around
with elements to add to the caffeine for
the performance.
And then we had a guy that we work with,
I think for about three years he'd, we'd
have guys come over and they'd be like,
Hey,
can you make me one of those coffees?
And after a while they'd start
sending me emails like, well,
how much coconut and how much of
this and how much that did he put in.
And our friend Paul was like,
do you mind if I try to put it together
in a formula? And I was like, yeah,
whatever. And it wasn't with the
intention of having a business.
And then before you know
it, it came out. And, uh,
so then we have like original creamer
with unsweetened, there's Tumeric,
there's hydrate products. Um, you know,
it's all based on things that
layered really eats and uses and,
uh, you know, mushroom
blends that I actually put,
that's how I do my coffee in the mornings.
I put that in and, and do that. So,
you know,
that's another good example of like if
you're doing something because you really
believe in it and really, um,
and that business has, um,
we're really fortunate. It's, we
have a factory in sisters, Oregon,
and they built another one and,
wow. Yeah, no, it's, we have no,
like they do everything that no
co-packing partners. We do it. And, uh,
now we're looking into farming ingredients
and doing a drying factory so we can
do that and put that into the product
and things like that. So, I don't know,
I think it started from a genuine
passion and, and, and came into that.
And you know, I always say too, like I
started, I was playing volleyball at a t,
you know,
in college at 17.
And then I started working and was
sort of doing other jobs by 18 or 19,
but layered his path has
been really different.
And really he didn't get in
surfing. People like these
new, maybe new Hillard was,
he was sort of always on the outside,
but then it's,
it's really, he was like 35 years old
when someone from the outside went, oh,
that's Kinda cool. So 35 would be
considered old, I think for an athlete.
And I think it's somebody who thought,
I have something inside me
telling me to go forward.
And I think that I feel that same way.
Like people have said to me like, well,
why did you do this or that? I go,
cause I could feel it inside. It's like,
you know that from what you do because
you've done a lot of different things and
um, and just kind of not
only trying to develop that,
but try to trust it and
say, even though I've, I've,
you know, it, I don't see
it all clearly right now.
I feel it and I'm gonna just
keep following that feeling.
And it doesn't always lead to some
grand destination, but maybe that,
those lessons and that place leads you
to the next, which could be, you know,
the place that you know, brings
you other things. So yeah,
these businesses are just a
natural byproduct of our lifestyle,
but it's pretty great. It's
pretty awesome. It's stuff.
I didn't start drinking coffee
till I was 45 really? Yeah.
Cause I Laird would be like,
cause I think he was like,
try this one and try that and try this.
I like to caffeine.
I just wasn't into coffee.
How would you take it?
Like you're Rahmati teams and stuff. I get
all jacked up on that side, that stuff.
You ever drink that stuff?
It's good stuff.
You better go straight
to whatever you're doing.
Because I have a year Mamata and I'm
like, tell me kids, you get your stuff.
We are in the car, you have your
bags. And they're just like, dude,
did you have a year? Bramante you
know, like you're a crazy person. So,
and now I've switched to the
caffeine with the fats. Um, but I,
I like it and I liked the business
aspect of it quite frankly. Like for me.
That's interesting too,
you know. Well thank you.
I'll send you more on podcasts.
Do you do podcast?
I had a podcast with Neil Strauss
and just stopped doing it. Yeah.
Neil's a busy guy. And, uh, we had
a podcast, we did it in the sauna.
We called the truth barrel.
That's what it was called.
We were literally in the sauna in
our bathing suits because our group,
when we get together, we were, we would
sit in the sauna and you know this,
if you have friends over, you go, hey, you
know what, I'm having love problems. Okay,
we got eight minutes because 200 degrees,
like let's get into it.
You're half naked, so you're
sort of, there you are.
And so I got an invitation
to do a podcast. And so I
saw Neil and I are so very,
very different, like
really different. And uh,
I thought it'd be more interesting to
have us with our points of view. Um,
and cause then you also realize that
as different as we are is we're really
looking for the same things.
We're trying to figure out love.
We're trying to be parents, we're trying
to work, take care of ourselves, age,
whatever,
all this stuff you're navigating.
And so we did that for like a year
and a half. It was a lot of fun.
And people like in there
in their bathing suit,
sweating at my house in the sauna in
the truth barrel because that's what we
always called it. You can't lie in the
sauna like 10 minutes long. Now we would,
we would open the door.
Oh but it was like an,
I tried to turn it way down cause Laird
has our sauna two to 2120 go in there
cook. No it's exactly right.
But if you coupled with the ice,
you're sort of grateful for
the two 20 so I would turn it,
I tried to turn it down to like one 20
and inevitably the next day when it was
our real life Sonim alerts like who's
been messing with the dial in my sauna?
You know, it's like this whole thing
and I'm like, well, we were shooting,
we can't sit in there for an hour. You
see people, they're like, can I go out?
And they jump in the pool and then
come back in. It was really fun.
I liked it because there's something
like you just get right to it. Right?
Well why don't you just do it on your own?
You know what Joe,
I listened to your podcast
a lot and I think to myself,
very few people can do what you do.
I think it's really important to not
only like recognize when someone does
something really well cause
everyone thinks I could do
that. It's like, well, no,
you can't actually. Um, and so for me,
I'm very curious about
people and you know,
I used to do a lot of TV
where I'd interview athletes.
Like that was more interesting to me
than being interviewed because, um,
that's how you've learned.
Like you go, okay, how do you
do it? I know how I do it.
I don't need to know that I need
to know what you're doing. And, um,
I just think it's, it
does interest me, but I,
I would want to do it right.
Um,
and not just assume like you can
do it because to do it really well,
it's a special talent. Uh, I
just had a lot of practice.
We'd go back and listen to the early ones.
They sucked.
Just you just get better at it.
Yeah. No and I get that too.
But I think it's just knowing,
I think this is important in all things
in life because we like something not,
not maybe for me,
because I do really like this is just
because we like something doesn't mean we
have to do that too.
Like I think it's still like drilling
down on, you know, what do you want to do?
Like, cause when I hear you, you go
from a comedian to like a scientist,
a physicist to, you know, it's like,
it shows your genuine
passions in all these areas.
And that's what's interesting.
I mean I always want to talk
about like how do you get it done?
I'm so interested in how people,
if they can arrive at any place where
there's a sense of like joy moving in and
out of their life and self care.
And because I think when people talk
about health and fitness or wellness,
I think they're off the mark about
what it really is. I think for me,
what I've learned is like
I train in eat well just so I have a
fighting chance to support any kind of
happiness. Um, and it isn't just
about like I'm ripped, you know,
not me, but like the notion of what people
are putting out there that fitnesses.
It's like that's all great,
but if you still haven't figured out
some of these other things as a person,
it's like, I don't know. It seems like
you're wrestling the wrong things.
So I'm always really interested in and
also in not only how they get it done,
but also not making it seem like it's so
easy. You know? It's like when people,
I always joke, like when
people do interviews and they
go, how are your children?
Oh my God, they're amazing. And
I'm like, my kids are amazing too.
And they,
you know,
crush our balls on daily basis and
isn't that everybody's house, you know,
or people who say to me, I mean,
do you alert ever fight? Um,
I mean we have and we haven't
always had perfect, you know,
like there's been times where it was like
maybe we're not going to stay together.
And I guess for me that would be really
interesting is to communicate in a way
that's like, it's not gratuitous
but at least like, hey,
you're being kind of honest
about like what it is,
you know? And, and, and
now like I'm almost 50,
it's like even aging,
like having a,
having a realistic but good conversation
about like, hey, how's that going?
You know, not like I feel
great. I do feel great. I do,
I feel great. I'm sure you do. But there
are days where you, you go, oh time,
a real human time's moving.
I said sometimes I say that
teleric cause you know,
you don't want to be that wife. Do I look
all too? It's like he doesn't notice.
You know what I mean? I say,
I said today, it was funny,
I had a thing like I realized like
time's moving and he goes [inaudible]
because he knows what that
means and I'm sparing him that
conversation cause that's like
a girlfriend conversation.
That's like not one that
you have with your partner.
I think it's important to like,
you know,
go down the hole with
them on other things.
I do observe that sometimes
I look outside and I go,
yeah this is not a conversation
you want to have with Laird.
Save that for you know,
your, your girlfriend.
You have so much to say.
I think it's like a natural progression
for you to do another podcast for di to
do your own.
I don't know,
so much bouncing around like
I'm so boring to not boring. No,
I swear to God I've,
I feel like, you know,
it's probably cause you
think about yourself so much,
you're probably annoyed that
you thinking about yourself.
Try to fix this and change that
and adapt here and evolve their,
you know,
if you're really paying attention,
even a decent athlete is,
is like I was just trying to,
I was just trying to get it and I know
as a human we can never get it right and
that's a moving target.
But I feel like the pursuit of trying
to be one's best self in the is is
probably worth spending some time on.
Um,
you, you appreciate your existence
more I think when you are on that path.
I think so.
And I think,
I think especially when you've had the
opportunity also to do a lot of really
cool stuff and must think it becomes
a responsibility because you're not
fighting certain fights, like
certain battles. You don't even have,
like I don't have to, I have three
jobs, but I chose three jobs.
It's not like you're just trying
to survive like those people.
It's like, Hey, I get it. But I
felt like if you go like, Hey,
I got to do that and this and this. It's
like, yeah, cool. What are you doing?
Like what, what else are
you going to do? You know,
I think that that becomes a worthy task.
And I,
and also like I'm trying to stay in my,
I'm trying to stay married,
I'm trying to be a decent mom,
things like that.
And so that takes probably some work.
Well it does,
but I really think that there's value
in expressing that and that you do.
Yes I do. Yeah. I'm sure a lot of people
are agreeing right now like, yeah,
do a podcast. You know
what it is. This is what I,
my ultimate hope would be is that somehow,
and this is I think why I love your show
because I hear it over and over and you
don't say it per se of saying it, but
it's there always in an underlying way.
It's like power and love always like be
your most Badass self all the time that
you can have fun,
kick ass and maybe behind like for me
those are the ultimate because every,
all the people that I
see lower, I'm like, oh,
they could kick your ass and love you.
You know,
I that's really powerful.
I mean, I respond to that
because it, you know,
it feels important right now.
I think you're absolutely right.
I think this is a good way to
end this. Okay. Let's do it.
[inaudible] so thank you. Thanks for
being here. I really appreciate it.
I really enjoyed it. Thank you.
Um, tell people your Instagram,
your social media and Gabby Reece,
if they want to check out
the pool training XPT and
just get people to take care of
themselves. Mahalo. Bye everybody.